tous les plus grands tournois d'échec il
se déroule en présentiel ou en ligne
vivez comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
bases retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats des comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition aux
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur les tickets vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs émoticônes
et les emojis disparaîtront au bout de
quelques secondes en revanche les
notations de coûts et les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce jour
2 du tata style chess India rapide et
Blitz c'est le jour de pour le rapide
avec évidemment
l'homme qui joue plus vite que son ombre
Maxime va chez Lagrave le champion du
monde de Blitz 2021 numéro 1 français
pendant de nombreuses années et encore
encore évidemment
un des toutous meilleurs joueurs du
monde
spécialement rapide et il nous habitué à
faire de tellement beaux résultats on va
suivre tout ça on va voir que ça se
passe bien pour l'instant pour Maxime on
l'a on a tout en place on a Maxime
Vacher La Grave là qui est à l'écran on
va regarder bonjour à tous évidemment
dans le chat et ailleurs
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce c'est
rapide qui sont tellement tellement
excitant à suivre on a encore deux jours
de rapides et ensuite on aura deux jours
de Blitz
et je serai avec vous tout le temps à
partir de 11h30 comme aujourd'hui on va
faire un petit tour du côté du standing
et la Bonne Nouvelle regardez la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on a Raja bof gamer
Maxime lâcher Lagrave et goûtech avec
deux points sur trois alors évidemment
rien n'est joué mais c'est un bon départ
pour Maxime
qui a hier la dernière partie quand de
visite qui nous a fait quand même un
petit peu peur mais dans son style si
particulier la réussite à créer des
problèmes dans une position très
compromise selon l'ordinateur mais il a
su créer des problèmes il a su faire
déjouer vite qui du coup se retrouve à
un sur trois on voit 50 % en après
lambda le héros de la Coupe du Monde qui
a perdu simplement au final face à
manuscrite et abdosa torov
donc on va suivre tout ça on va regarder
les appareils en de cette rencontre 4 3
rondes aujourd'hui c'est du 25 + 10 je
le rappelle trois rentes demain aussi et
pour cette rencontre 4 Maxime aura les
blancs en façade Vincent gamer des
colliders on aura aussi i Krishna
rajabov Abdou Sator programme
mais évidemment
la partie qu'on va suivre en premier
ce sera entre Maxime Vacher La Grave et
Vincent gamer donc on va la suivre comme
ça j'ai préparé aussi
quelque chose une spéciale où on peut se
mettre dans le public regarder hop je
suis dans le public on va pousser ça
ah c'est ballot ça
je comprends pas pourquoi ça marche plus
j'avais mis des pendules et tout
ça marche plus
pour l'instant j'avais mis des pendules
mais on voit les deux joueurs qui sont
là
je comprends pas pourquoi ça marche plus
ah parce qu'il y a pas de pendule pour
l'instant vous allez voir ah oui non
mais je comprends j'ai compris ouais
j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur que mon
réglage et on voit le début de la partie
et vous voyez on aura le temps des deux
joueurs si on suit sur cette image
on aura le temps vous voyez c'est ce
qu'on va faire reproché hier est-ce
qu'on voit bien ou pas ouais on voit
bien le temps des deux joueurs voyez et
on peut suivre comme ça et on a une
écossaise alors là surprise mais
évidemment je vais reprendre le
liveboard et une écossaise une surprise
de la part de Maxime Vacher Lagrave lui
qui a tellement bon joueur
de d'espagnol alors l'espagnol je vais
vous montrer ce que c'est l'espagnol
ah le liveboard je me suis trompé dans
le liveboard donc je vais corriger ça
tout de suite
je vais corriger ça tout de suite
c'est le début évidemment du
chaud donc il y a toujours deux trois
petites corrections
à faire
liveboard non
je comprends pas
ah bon alors
je sais pas vous voyez le petit liveborn
c'est le petit liveboard qui m'inquiète
à gauche mais on va voir on va voir tout
ça évidemment ensuite il joue ce H4 qui
est très agressif et
donc oui mieux aligner ça serait ça
serait bien notre zik oui évidemment que
je vais faire ça j'ai mieux aligné mais
là j'étais en mode il jouait pas vous
voyez on peut pas faire les tests je
pensais que c'était plus aligné que ça
effectivement c'est pas très bien aligné
on alignera tout ça et H4 très très
agressif de la part de Maxime dans cet
écossaise
qui commence comme ça donc joueur
espagnol j'avais joué des fous j'ai joué
comme les Espagnols avec les Noirs
contre Maxime beaucoup
beaucoup au moins 5 ou 6 avec les Noirs
mais l'écossais c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très rare mais l'effet de
surprise en partie rapide très important
et ce coup H4 très 2023 et la tour qui
peut venir là le fou qui peut venir là
plusieurs coups ici moi-même j'ai joué
D6 qui est un des coûts les plus logique
qui tout de suite tout de suite on
s'attaque
au centre avec une attaque évidemment
allez le roi on prend de l'espace certes
mais normalement on réagit au centre
donc soit des six soit F6 ce sont les
deux coups recommandés on va voir ce que
va décider gamer pendant ce temps je
vais essayer de régler j'ai un petit
souci sur le
live board
je comprends pas d'où ça vient
non
ça c'est assez c'est assez étrange
un board
elle arrive board bon
bizarre
non OK
ce que je vais faire c'est je suis
désolé pas encore atteint le coup de
gamer qui réfléchit sur cette position
bon il réfléchit choisir il est pas du
tout il connaît les souvenirs sont
vagues mais effectivement il connaît
rien il y a pas de il y a pas de souci
sur ça
une nouvelle fenêtre non pas du tout
c'est là ouais
et
on va chercher la partie de Maxime comme
ça vous pouvez suivre votre rythme sur
le live ça j'aime bien et c'est une
demande qu'on va faire assez
régulièrement
et vous pouvez évidemment regarder mes
flèches sur le grand échiquier
voilà normalement
ça devrait marcher
et pas du tout
bon bah à la pause à la pause je m'en
voilà liveboard donc là vous verrez et
vous voyez que quand je reviens ici ça
marche toujours sur molo liveboard qui
est à gauche vous pouvez réfléchir sur
la position de chez kietricola je vous
montre les flèches et tout ce qu'on la
théorie les variantes qu'on peut
envisager et voilà donc ça c'est très
connu et H4 il joue dans le 6 d'abord
pour jouer des sites on peut aussi
sortir le fou c'est vrai que c'est un
des grands coups aussi dame aussi c'est
pas du tout une surprise pour Maxime
simplement il a réfléchi 4 minutes quand
même gamer cette jeune génération qui a
pas peur de se mettre mal au temps d'un
mecisse devrait être pas être une
surprise je crois que j'ai trois ici
existent pour jouer fois 3
C4 est toujours une option à regarder
on peut aussi continuer en jouant à 5
mais alors on néglige quand même le
développement donc compliqué
merci merci à tous de pour les mots
gentils et de me rejoindre
ouais alors surprise notre zik
à moitié surpris parce que évidemment
qu'il est surpris mais il connaît
quelque chose c'est à dire qu'il a il a
quand même il a quand même déjà regardé
ça c'est sûr
et dame aussi c'est clairement un coup
un coup j'ai déjà vu
pour sortir le fou simplement de case
noire ici ou ici
maxima jouet qui a des deux qui est
aussi traité Matic et les deux pourquoi
parce que des gens pas le mettre en C3
en se ferait échanger et la structure de
pions serait endommagé
et donc il est deux on va aller là et
ensuite attention on peut toucher la
dame par là ou par là donc tout à fait
logique
qui a aidé deux
alors maintenant c'est la grande
question pour les Noirs est-ce qu'on
fait des six est-ce qu'on continue
tranquillement avec fossette
est-ce qu'on essaie parce que le
problème de cahier des deux c'est ça
laisse ce pion en C2 un petit peu en
l'air donc et des deux vous voyez
cavalier F3 par exemple on pourra
envisager fois 6 quelque chose assez
agressif et attention à la dame bon
alors parfois hein parfois on joue dame
qu'est-ce qu'on joue on joue plutôt C4
là honnêtement on peut jouer plutôt C4
pour voilà et c'est d'enfermer ses
pièces on peut aussi c'est ce que je
voulais montrer là je pense à pas
marcher parce qu'il y aura foo.fr c'est
ce que je monte et on peut jouer avec le
roi on peut jouer avec le roi qui va là
avant après on va pousser on va faire ça
mais je crois qu'il y a un problème
tactique ici ce qui serait dame C4 échec
et on va encaisser ce pion en C2 qui est
attaqué deux fois
donc et des deux lors du choix pour
Vincent gamer et on voit l'ambition de
Maxime qui veut capitaliser sur sa
victoire de dernier rang d'hier
à l'équipe composée de mvl on a donné
une info hier on a dit qu'il était pas
que le second en tout cas je sais pas
quel est exactement l'équipe mais le
second emprein principal il n'est pas il
n'est apparemment pas
français
alors apprendre avec des pincettes
à moins que ce soit Laurent Blanc on
était pas sûr hier on se dit Laurent
Blanc Laurent Blanc peut arriver dans
l'équipe de MTN
alors gamer qui réfléchit ça c'est une
très bonne nouvelle évidemment parce que
c'est une position très complexe et donc
de le voir réfléchir aussitôt et bien ça
vraie avantage pour pour Maxime
qui comme on l'a vu hier mais une grosse
pression au temps il est vraiment il est
très fort sur ça et il met il met
beaucoup de pression il a joué un peu
vite hier il s'est retrouvé en danger
contre programme lambda et Vidy mais à
la fin c'était quand même
c'était concluant
c'était très concluant en tout cas le
score le score de sur 3 et
excellent avec deux noirs on le rappelle
donc là il aura deux blancs aujourd'hui
et donc ça s'annonce pas mal tout ça il
réfléchit joue Kai B4 gamer je vous en
parlais qui est mes quatre faut que ça
marche c'est très très concret
le seul coup vraiment pour protéger ces
deux de manière adéquate
si on fait cavalier 4 attention pion
donc ça n'irait pas
donc je crois est vraiment le coup et il
est joué assez rapidement par Maxime va
chier la grave
ouais possible alors je suis battu
merci bonjour serdock et merci je
battuce qui nous demande possible de
jouer B3 pour qu'elle C4 ouais alors
c'est un peu lent dans ce genre de de
variante et en plus là il y avait une
vraie menace mais c'est vrai que B3 et
souvent une option dans ces dans ces
écossaises avec le cavalier qui vient
plutôt là quand même et le pion qui
vient en C4 c'est plutôt ça pour quand
même essayer de challenger un petit peu
ce cavalier en dessin qui est quand même
une très belle pièce pour les Noirs donc
x 6 et bien
voilà il joue de manière très concrète
la jeune génération
C4 jouer par Maxime va chez Lagrave vous
voyez je vous en parlais
et maintenant c'est très dangereux
stratégiquement parce que vous voyez ces
pièces elles sont un peu enfermées la
dame un petit coup de la 3 une menace
tout simplement grosse menace alors
peut-être c'est ça qui veut faire
c'est 5 pour sur A3 se replacer par là
mettre le foulard éventuellement un coup
de grand rock il y a aussi le coup de
dessin toujours regarder si des 5
marches
ça paraît très un petit peu surprenant
que des 5 marches mais comment ça serait
réfuter ça serait pas si évident non
plus en tout cas ça me saute pas aux
yeux
la réfutation de ce dessin peut-être non
puis on prend on va y avoir puis on
prend tout simplement puis on prend puis
on prend ça va pas du tout
apparemment il y avait même dame prend
dam prank elle est pas du tout pour les
attentions on peut on peut se retrouver
très vite très actif avec les Noirs donc
faut faire attention donc sur des 5 ça
va un coup de pied j'ai 5 un coup de
cahier des 4 à voir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici
ok des 4
qui est des 4 Antoine G33 qui nous dit
Kate ouais alors certes cahier des Caps
mais bon si je bouge la dame je vois pas
trop ce que ça
ce que ça fait
par exemple ici ou ici et la page de ça
il a joué C5 l'autre idée gamer des 5
Paris c'est vraiment trop dangereux et
même sur des 5 d'ailleurs on pouvait
jouer pour jouer simplement B3 c'était
pas très clair ce que les Noirs ah non
c'est pas bon V3 quel était le coup là
je vais regarder je triche c'était A3
il faut le savoir OK
et vous voyez ce genre d'idée on va
prendre ici on va prendre du roi
le cavalier va venir là on va faire
cailler des quatre on va faire de ma 4
on va attaquer très vite et ce cavalier
complètement hors-jeu ça c'est
compensation typique de l'écossaise
Maxime devait connaître c'est quand même
probable que ce qui soit encore en
territoire connu
donc c'est 5 pour rapatrier le cavalier
par là on ouvre la grande diagonale le
fou va se replacer mais les blancs
gagnent du temps donc attention
attention pour gamer qui on le rappelle
a été riche champion du monde de partir
rapide cette année c'est pour vous dire
c'est pour dire à quel point ce jeune
joueur est dangereux Vincent gamer le
principal espoir allemand clairement
numéro 1 allemand assez clairement
alors Maxime qu'est-ce qui va nous faire
est-ce qu'il va sortir de est-ce qu'il
va décider de sortir son fou par là
est-ce qu'il va continuer est-ce qu'il
va faire un coup de cavalier qui peut
attaquer la dame attention il faut pas
aller n'importe où avec les Noirs non
plus parce que si on va là par exemple
j'aurais peut-être dame F3 ici attaque
double attaque et attaque la tour donc
faut faire attention un petit peu avec
la case mais il semble que dame C6 quoi
que dame c'est 6 c'est pas sûr parce
qu'il y a trois
c'est très très complexe ce genre de
chose peut-être que G5 D6 c'est mieux
même G6
alors Saddam G6
vous voyez c'est très complexe à jouer à
jouer sans la jauge c'est compliqué
ah salut à toi
salut à torche skate chess
habitué des chauds
alors ok j'ai ça il me semblerait très
tentant qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur kg5
c'est quand même une grande question ah
peut-être dame F5 évidemment vous êtes
la case
nageuse ne bouge pas trop mais
énormément d'options pour les noirs sur
kg 5 quels sont les options pour les
pour Maxime ici c'est pas si clair à mon
avis
parce que le problème de G3 fois H3
c'est que ce pion
c'est que ce pion en C4 va se retrouver
en l'air donc va falloir perdre un temps
avec B3 quoi que B3 a un coup standard
ouais je réfléchis à voix haute sur ce
genre de position c'est très complexe
quand on a pas joué j'ai jamais joué ce
genre de truc avec les Blancs
c'est très compliqué alors l'écossaise
pour faire un petit pitch c'était pas du
tout une ouverture
à la mode ça jamais été à la mode on a
toujours eu des
Espagnols et quand même là variante
principale mais Gary kasporov est revenu
est venu avec cette petite surprise pour
un atelier carpov à l'époque match de
Lyon New York Lyon 1990
et il est arrivé avec cette surprise de
l'écossaise une surprise qui a très bien
marché vu qu'il a marqué un et demi sur
deux
et en pressant la deuxième avec les
Blancs et donc après il en a rejoué
quelques-unes et quelques victoires
spectaculaires très bon score de kaspard
of dans dans l'écossais donc
[Musique]
honnêtement c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui est hyper la
mode mais il faut c'est quelque chose
il faut s'y attendre voilà ça ça peut
arriver c'est pas complètement exclu et
Yann et pomyachi est un des
joueurs même s'il a pas joué en machin
pas du monde il a joué des Espagnols
mais en tout cas il a beaucoup joué
d'écossaises à l'époque
à l'époque c'était il y a pas si
longtemps que ça
et joue à trois en disant par qui est 6
et fouder 2 contrôle la case à 5 avalée
à 5 pour être une menace pour attaquer
ce pion et prépare aussi le grand rock
donc sur Grand Roc qui paraît maintenant
assez logique
et bien je crois qu'on fera pareil avec
les Blancs et on a cette structure qui
peut être très agréable on peut être le
foin en C3 la dame en E4 le four en des
trois sortir tranquillement toutes nos
pièces et avoir une belle position
Magnus en joue pas mal aussi non non il
a joué quelques unes justement quand il
travaillait kasparoff mais depuis il en
joue très très peu une fois tu as
entendu une très belle partie en Coupe
d'Europe
sur l'écossaise ou la caméra qui saute
ou la caméra qui saute
ou la caméra sauter aspire donc ça
revienne
espérant que ça revienne
bon on a léger souci de caméra
sur la partie de mvl mais on espère que
ça va revenir
regardez j'ai même une scène avec toutes
les cames je la montre vite fait
mais VL à sauter ah non elle est revenue
ok c'est un petit assistant technique
chez nos amis indiens qui franchement
nous
c'est sympa leurs images sont très très
bien faites on les remercie
un vrai boom des échecs en Inde j'ai pu
le vivre je suis allé à Chennai l'année
dernière aux Olympiques je peux vous
garantir
c'était assez incroyable
pour aller à la salle de jeux pour
ressortir la salle de jeux il y avait un
nombre incalculable de fans et en plus
il demandait pas des alors ils
demandaient des photos des autographes
et tout ça mais au moment je me suis dit
je me suis demandé si il savait vraiment
qui en était je pensais qu'il faut
essayer que les meilleurs et en fait ils
connaissent ils connaissent ces échecs
il y a plein qui m'ont dit oui seconde
en Magnus et tout ça voilà donc vraiment
il y a un vrai engouement et une vraie
amour du jeu
donc c'est c'est beau à voir et
effectivement quand elle publique il y a
des il y a des tournois qui sont
organisés tout simplement
c'est aussi simple que ça ça marche
comme ça
Maxime qui comme à son habitude se
baladent un petit peu
est-ce que alors j'ai vu tout à l'heure
ouais les joueurs
les joueurs non on a pas on n'a pas on
n'a pas la vue de du côté de Maxime
mais ouais les joueurs essaient de
s'habiller vous voyez ils mettent une
petite chemise bon ben voilà c'est de je
sais pas si c'est obligatoire mais bon
c'est quand même convenu
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
ça se fait quoi tu auras fermer comme ça
sur 10 joueurs quelque chose qui se fait
est fou des deux faut cette fou c'est
trois en contrôle bien ses cases il
attend peut-être sur petit roc il veut
jouer dame 4 suivi de fou des trois ok
G5 petit exemple très dangereux mais il
faut être beaucoup de développement
empêche plus ou moins que j'ai 5 on
prendrait certainement en plus il y a le
pion 5 je raconte des bêtises mais faut
cette écoute développement pour voir
aussi comment Maxime s'organise ou ces
trois et là c'est un peu le
le jeu du chat et de la souris où est-ce
que tu rock
je pense pas que que Maxime
que Maxime
rock de l'autre côté je pense que grand
rock quand même est assez
normal avec la tour en
désolé pour le bruit si vous l'entendez
si vous entendez le bruit vous me dites
je vais fermer la fenêtre de ce pas
et petit travaux en face vous savez
c'est pareil
Paris les travaux là
les JO je pense qu'on va avoir des
travaux déjà à il y avait des travaux là
on va en voir beaucoup parce qu'ils font
le BTP
ça passe en temps r on entend mais ça va
d'accord
là c'est vraiment là c'est la c'est le
coup de perceuse là voilà je vais aller
faire mais je vais ouvrir après j'arrive
dans 10 secondes
c'est vraiment l'immeuble en face
donc
c'est fini est-ce que j'ai déjà joué au
tata style oui j'ai vu le groupe B avec
un
groupe B deux fois deux fois
après c'est particulier le tata style de
we canzé il y a quand même il y a 13
rondes ça se joue en quasi 3 semaines
avec les avec les joints de repos
il vaut mieux vaut mieux que ça se passe
bien quand ça se passe mal c'est l'enfer
on va juste envie de partir
alors on va voir
on va voir
on va voir ce qui se passe ce qui décide
gamer il prend beaucoup de temps 8
minutes de moins on a vu que ça a joué
un très mauvais tour très mauvais tour
à gamer à visite hier alors attention
c'est joueurs là aiment bien prendre
leur temps mais attention quand même
attention ça s'est bien passé une fois
où j'ai failli gagner
figurez-vous dans ce 3B j'avais
un point et demi d'avance j'étais
premier avec un point de vidange un 6
ronde de la fin
et un point d'avance à 3 honte de la fin
j'ai fini 3e
oh c'était chez Molly sur la fin et le
deuxième c'était un désastre le deuxième
aussi je suis remonté sur la fin bizarre
enfin je suis remonté je suis remonté
j'étais à -3 on est où quand donc - 3
c'est 3 défaites de plus que que de
victoire et j'ai gagné j'ai gagné deux
dernières je crois
les gens n'ont pas besoin de noter si 25
+ 10 on rappelle la cadence rapide jour
1 non il faut que je chante c'est jour 2
ah c'est le jour 2
c'est le jour 2 je changerai ah c'est
ballot ça alors
ouais là je me suis voyez c'est le jour
on va le changer et F6 jouer oulala il
s'attaque directement au centre de
Maxime Vacher la grave
et bien
c'est intéressant alors c'est très
coûterait responsable clairement parce
que surpuis on prend F6 on va avoir une
structure pas terrible par exemple vous
prend vous prend puis on prend
ouais alors oui oui mais bon vous voyez
hein la structure de pion est quand même
pas terrible on a 4 îlots de pions
contre simplement de
donc vous voyez que stratégiquement pour
la finale c'est quand même assez risqué
après ces dynamiques si par exemple je
prends ici on se dit et puis on oublie
mais regardez il y a une belle case en
D4 on peut voir le four en B7 ça peut
très vite très vite s'améliorer pour les
Noirs oui oui c'était en classique le
tata style à avec un peu le Wimbledon
des échecs ce tournoi existe depuis très
peu de temps très honnêtement ce tournoi
je crois est la première édition a eu
lieu en 2019 avec la victoire
de l'inévitable
alors F6 intéressant
on peut aussi laisser prendre parfois
sacrifier des pions jouer grand rock
quelque chose comme ça quelque chose
comme ça serait pas quoi
j'ai trois fois je crois mais là il y a
cahier des 4 je pense ça ça pose quand
même un problème et en plus il y aurait
pu en C4 aussi donc ça n'irait pas
donc grand OK et clairement une option
surpuis on prend on peut faire cavalier
prend et voyez quand même on est assez
actif la jauge j'aime bien quand j'aime
bien on est content donc grand rock
semble être un coup
clairement
comment je fais je me souviens plus
comment on fait pour changer
je veux changer maintenant ça m'agace ce
jour 1 vous voyez en haut en haut à
droite
pourquoi forcément partir sur grand rock
parce que
tu joues un coup tu mets ton roi à
l'abri dans un coup c'est ça le concept
est-ce que là bonne chance pour faire
petit rock il va falloir que j'ai trois
un deux et ça sera le troisième coup
donc voilà pourquoi je pars sur sur
Grand Roc et Maxime on est arrivé à la
même conclusion
parce que ça va plus vite tout
simplement mais son roi à l'abri
beaucoup plus vite
je suis sur Obs ouais
comment on fait déjà
pour changer sans que je vous j'ai
oublié oh là là c'est pas brillant
c'est pas brillant mais synchrozel je
sens qu'il va m'aider
je sens qu'il va m'aider sans que je
fasse une bêtise
mon caisse
activer la perçu
bon je me souviens plus alors en parlant
d'écossaise
[Musique]
ouais
alors le poulet de Belgique qui parle
d'écossaise oui dame de jouer des
Français 3 ouais
exactement j'ai pas 2005 le poulet de
Belgique mais excellente remarque
c'était en 2004 j'ai perdu contre
[Musique]
Ikaru Nakamura ouais effectivement il
m'a un peu derrière on en plus donc la
dernière on était très importantes
j'avais encore de l'avance à ce
moment-là et j'ai perdu la dernière
contre moi qui était un jeune joueur
plein d'avenir apparemment et donc très
fort il a parlé Nakamura d'ailleurs j'ai
vu une cantine nous a
un petit peu on a un petit peu
chatouiller sur sur mon podcast chicken
Chess Club n'hésitez pas à aller voir en
anglais
on l'a on l'a un petit peu chatouillé il
a dit il a dit que oui il a rappelé
cette partie il s'est trompé de date
2005 il a dit mais bon ça va ça restait
ça restait sympathique non parce qu'on
disait que son répertoire était quand
même assez solide et justement il a
parlé de cette partie où il a fait un
Gambier écossais et il avait fait une
très belle partie d'attaque et voilà
mais bon
son style a changé depuis 20 ans
alors
F6 pion pro M6 maintenant donc grand
rock comme je vous l'avais dit il
attendait de faire grand rock il attend
et de voir
l'adresse du roi blanc pour donner son
adresse puis on prend un F6
et
on va certainement faire un F6
parce que ce fou est très fort puis on
prend
je pense que ce fou est quand même plus
actif que celui-là non il a rien fait
d'abord faut prendre de F6 maintenant
comme je vous l'ai dit il faut prendre
F6 j'ai pris un F6 et maintenant on a
cette petite finale avec cette fameuse 4
contre 4 pions
4 contre 2 pardon contre deux îlots de
pions
et donc effectivement c'est plutôt un
jeu pour les blancs mais alors attention
c'est pas fini on peut on peut
éventuellement essayer de mettre le
cavalier par là mais en tout cas ça a
l'air quand même sympathique pour les
blancs à jouer cette position
alors je sais plus le poulet de Belgique
on fait pas un épisode entier sur
Nakamura on répond à Nakamura
on répond on parle de moi
et après il y a ces gens du chat qui
fait ça très souvent
il fait en direct il écoute
et il répond
il nous fait passer pour des pour des
nazes
c'est de bonne guerre
alors
comment on fait maintenant ici ça va
faire nul ça va faire nul c'est pas sûr
on nous dit ça sur Youtube ça va faire
nul attention on voit ces deux rois C3
on peut jouer des B4 bon ça ça refait la
structure pour les
ça dédoublerait le pion le pion C mais
quand même ça reste jouable on voit
cette majorité de trois comptes 2 ici à
jouer pas mal de faiblesse il faut
s'organiser ici avec les Blancs on va
voir ce que va faire Maxime il a joué
tout rache1 très logique Maxime va chez
Lagrave qui ne m'oublie pas et qui joue
toujours très vite mettant la pression
sur la position et au temps à son jeune
adversaire Vincent gamer il se lève
il se lève Maxime très en confiance il a
bien raison ouh là là j'ai fait une
boulette toi je suis un
voilà je n'ai pas envie de faire ça OK
ouais il est à son bon fou non c'est pas
forcément un bon fou mais
il a un fou pas forcément un bon fou ni
un mauvais fou parce que vous voyez ce
fou ce fou qui va revenir là ça va être
pas mal il est principalement mieux
à cause de la structure clairement
clairement c'est un très très faible
aller le roi notamment
on peut imaginer des trois qui
arrive on va taper sur ce petit pion
peut-être faux 4 la tour peut parfois
s'infiltrer on peut améliorer le roi tu
est-ce que pour les noirs on voit pas
trop comment on va jouer
cavalier à 5 c'est ridicule demande
French chose probablement
je caille des deux c'est pas très clair
ce que tu as gagné attention tu m'as
créé une menace par exemple tu fais ça
je vais faire ça maintenant il y a un
vrai souci
en pousse
il y aura peut-être encore cahier des
quatre un coup de bol mais bon même ça
attention ça serait bien pour les blancs
ça serait bien si tu gagnes au pion le
problème c'est que tu gagnes pas le pion
parce qu'il y a qu'à l'idée de et donc
tu as mis ton cavalier au bord pour rien
du tout donc il jouera pas ça et il a
joué des six Vincent gamer D6 pourquoi
pour essayer de stabiliser cette case en
5 on met aussi vous voyez un tous les
pions quasiment sur noir on a le foot de
casse blanche donc ce fou va être va
être actif
que va jouer Maxime ici alors fous des
trois il y a cavalier 5 à regarder
c'est possible que ça soit rien du tout
pour les blancs
le bon le mauvais fou c'est comme le bon
chasseur et moi chasseur exactement le
gars tout à fait tu as tout à fait
raison c'est ça
c'est vraiment ça la structure est pas
vraiment définie ici elle est encore
mobile donc c'est dur de parler de bon
fous mauvais fou en fait ce qui est ce
qui est immobile ce qui est fixé pour
toujours a priori c'est les pions C4
c'est 5 quoi que même pas parce qu'on
peut faire roisser deux rois C3 B4 et on
va être obligé de faire quelque chose
avec les noms dans la structure est pas
fixée donc là c'est vraiment déjà moi
j'ai pas trop ces
concept de bons fous mauvais fou
mais encore la structure est pas fixée
ça n'existe pas clairement
alors food étroit cavalier E5 Antoine
G33 nous dit fou F5 ok certes mais roi
V8 et tu restes avec ton problème ici tu
vas être obligé de prendre ici et
rétablir la structure là ça pourrait
être ça c'est très bon scénario pour les
noirs on a refait la structure et on va
on a du travail pour toutes les tours
attention à ces pions qui peuvent se
révéler faible plus tard
donc que va faire notre ami
on en est là
et Maxime qui réfléchit fait bien c'est
une finale il y aura pas de grosse crise
de temps a priori
petit coup droit ces deux rois C3 ça
marche pas de pain je trouve
on améliore le roi on je sais pas si on
va faire B4 on peut on peut rien
promettre mais en tout cas on peut
on peut menacer
et ce qui est clair c'est que gamer
devrait y penser en permanence à ce B4
auteur d'un fabuleux parcours hier en
fabuleux excellence parcours sur le
point comptable en tout cas 2 sur 3 avec
une partie pas maîtrisée contre un
deuxième mais
nul quand même et la dernière pas
maîtriser non plus mais une victoire
victoire face à vidite qui fait du bien
au moral dans son style
et bien
si particuliers dans des complications
qui selon l'ordinateur quand même on a
un avantage complètement gagnant pour
les blancs mais c'est pas si simple avec
Maxime qui tend qui pose des problèmes
et une question de plus et
voilà et ça a payé
alors pourquoi ramener le roi plutôt que
de faire bet3 parce que j'ai envie
d'ajouter cette menace B4 son style
chaotique parfois parfois ça arrive mais
là c'est juste qu'il a il a pas très
bien joué le début voilà c'est tout il a
une position très difficile dans le
milieu de jeu
dans le milieu de jeu la transition
entre ouverture et milieu de jeu il a
une très bonne position très difficile à
défendre et donc voilà ça s'est mal
passé ensuite il a
il a pas il a pas essayé d'éviter les
complications et Maxime va chez Lagrave
qui joue roi des deux simplement pour me
faire mentir
paroisser de quelle est la différence
entre roi des deux et roi C2 c'est la
question quiz on gagne un mug
alors regardez les mecs collector
attention c'est collector c'est 24
pourquoi roi des deux est paroissé 2
bien je n'en sais rien je ne gagnerai
pas le mug
bon probablement ça change pas grand
chose protège 2 peut-être plus malin
plus malin plus malin de faire ça mais
bon prends la case aussi du cavalier
donc on peut pas tout avoir
et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas roi des
deux
protège ce four je vois pas d'autres
idées
oui c'est ça exactement
coût parce qu'on s'est contrôlé quand il
prend et tu reprends donc roi des deux
c'est vrai qu'il y a cahier des cas qui
existe ça a donné cahier des quatre mais
à ce moment on va prendre et c'est vrai
que ce pion va certainement être assez
faible
même foudet 3 ici pour essayer de faire
passer la tour attention à ses pions ça
ça peut être délicat très très vite pour
les pour les Noirs ça peut comment on
fait pour empêcher de tout recettes je
vois pas de bons moyens d'empêcher tout
recettes déjà
par exemple pour 8
je vais prendre
mais bon même ça
même ça
ça peut quand même assez mal tourner
avec ces deux pions passés
ça peut mal tourner pour les Noirs
peut-être même tout gagnant 5 d'abord
sur un peut-être tourner et la finale de
fou vont être compliqué parce que nous
on a vrai on a un beau lit dans H toi je
suis ton affaire échec
et les blancs sont quand même quasi
gagnants on peut aussi envisager tout
recettes pour aller par là et pousser ce
pion et amener le petit frère
donc ça ça pouvait être très délicat on
va voir ce que va nous jouer gamer
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué sur roi des deux
il a joué fou B7 ok vous voyez il met ce
fou sur cette grande diagonale c'est
beaucoup plus logique c'est la place de
ce fou en général
et Maxime 12 minutes 39 et là il a
rattrapé un petit peu de son retard
autant le joueur allemand
très intéressant de cette finale
peut-être je suis seul à être passionné
mais bon je trouve ça passionnant ce
genre de finale avec c'est déséquilibres
vous voyez un peu comme dans la
berlinoise
oublé mais on est un peu plus actif mais
la structure est pas terrible là le fait
que la structure soit vraiment
endommagée ici je pense qu'on fait un au
moins le gère avantage au blanc
comment on fait ici est-ce qu'on
continue notre plan on voit ces trois
fois
j'ai trois j'ai trois jouets par le
champion français et oui comme ça sur
cavaliero 5 on n'a pas le pion g de qui
traîne
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire ce
cavalier 5 ouh là là ça
coût d'intellectuel comme on dit pour
jouer qui H3 qui avait la F4
mais alors c'est quand même faut faire
attention parce qu'on peut mais quoique
des cinq on va simplement prendre je
actif j'essaye de punir ce qui est en
géant mais on va faire croire C3 est
très bien placé ici on va pouvoir faire
kayh3 KVF 4 ça va être pas mal du tout
pour les blancs donc j'ai trois
clairement pour empêcher sur cavaliero 5
je pense pas qu'il va y prendre parce
que si on prend le ce que je vous avais
dit la tour est fuite
ça serait encore non j'aime pas du tout
pour les blancs je pense qu'il veut
plutôt jouer un coup de cavalier
alors peut-être ici aussi pour aller là
et là et ensuite viser toutes ces cases
mais j'ai pas je serai plutôt tenté par
kg on va voir je suis curieux de voir
cavalier de 5 chez gamer
pour voir ce qui joue
c'est loin d'être beaucoup mieux j'en
sais rien moi franchement la jauge dit
que c'est pas beaucoup mieux que c'est
quasi égal
en vrai avec les Noirs je serai inquiet
devant la chéquier avec les Blancs et
avec les Blancs je pense que je suis
mieux
mais bon qu'est-ce que je vous dise moi
les échecs sont un jeu concret mais on
l'a vu finalement l'évaluation
d'ordinateur elle est pas si importante
ce qui est important c'est
c'est je suis sûr que les deux joueurs
pensent que les blancs sont mieux que
c'est des fendables mais que les blancs
sont mieux c'est intéressant d'avoir la
ravi mais
c'est ce qui me semble
on va voir en tout cas il fait à 5 gamer
OK et en gros il lui dit
ok genre j'améliore ma structure tu
pourras plus jamais B4 et maintenant
montre-moi tu as fait G3 ok bravo
comment vas-tu maintenant qu'est-ce que
tu fais qu'est-ce que tu joues et
effectivement c'est une bonne question
j'aime beaucoup ce coup à 5 parce que
les Blancs pas de menace direct pourquoi
ce jeter sur ce cavalier E5 comment on
améliore avec les Blancs les trois C3
mais roi ces trois problèmes de ce roi
ces trois tours 8 par exemple
et voyez ce fou toujours un petit peu en
l'air
donc pas si évident pour les blancs
donc à 5 ouais j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup comment il joue gamer il m'a
parlé mon ami justement encore parler du
chicken shake mon ami Yann Gustave Sun
qui est aussi sélectionneur de de
l'équipe allemande il m'a dit ce gars
qui meurt aux Olympiades il est bon lui
les autres bon ils font des erreurs les
autres de l'équipe qui ont quand même
2650 bon je joue un peu comme nous quoi
il voit des choses certes mais ils font
quand même des erreurs et tout ça gamer
il laisse pas grand chose au hasard et
donc il m'a dit que vraiment
y penser qu'il allait être qu'il allait
être très très fort à 27-50 25 50
minimum
donc une classe d'écart avec les autres
jeunes Allemands qui sont qui sont bons
aussi ils ont une nouvelle génération
qui est quand même qui est quand même
assez solide comme blueba home Collard
voilà des joueurs des jeunes joueurs
allemands qui sont très forts mais pas
au niveau de gamer qui a été formé à
l'école l'écho
à l'école les causes à 5 ans
on sent l'école
le coup de profilaxi
pas mal
pas mal du tout
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du côté de Maxime
maintenant et bien je n'en sais rien
pour faire là peut-être
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué ce qui est bien
avec Maxime c'est que normalement on
n'attend pas trop longtemps il a joué
trois ok finalement il fait ce plan là
c'est logique d'avoir le droit en C3 il
est centralisé
ouh là
pièce forte et faible de la position et
où elle serait mieux placée
c'est compliqué là les pièces sont bien
placées pour les noirs on peut sauter
ici en 5 je pense que le tout des pièces
sont bien placés le défaut je l'ai dit
depuis le début le défaut de la position
noire
c'est la structure de pion
les Blancs ont les pièces très bien
placés évidemment on aimerait on
aimerait occuper cette couronne ouverte
et en profiter mais c'est pas si simple
parce que dès qu'on bouge le fou il y a
cavalier 5
donc il y a un vrai problème par exemple
des trois qui avaient lieu 5 le roi C3
admettons qu'est-ce qu'il a joué gamer
il a joué 5 finalement OK et que j'ai un
jouet je vous en parlais de ce kg il a
été joué à tempo f4k
donc maintenant ce qui va venir au 5 et
très bien placé par pourquoi parce que
si on fait F4 qui est le seul moyen de
le chasser on va reculer et ensuite ce
pur en G3 restera une faiblesse
le plan des blancs c'est de faire quel
âge 3 cavalier F4
et on peut éventuellement envisager le
cah-5 pour attaquer ici ou cahier des 5
si le fou part d'ici ce que je pense que
échanger le ce fou contre le cavalier ça
serait une bon un bon deal pour les pour
les noirs
ouais c'est mon genre de coup ok ça
j'aime bien j'aime bien ce genre de
choses le centre est fermé vous voyez il
y a pas de rupture le truc que je
regardais tout de suite c'était des 6
dessins mais là ça marche pas du tout
encore plus quand le roi et en C3
Laurent C3 qui est quand même assez bien
placé et donc maintenant pour les Noirs
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire 6-20 contre 9
34 j'aime beaucoup la prestation de
Maxime jusqu'à présent
c'est intéressant la jauge n'aime la
chose n'est pas impressionné je suis
plus impressionné que la jauge mais bon
j'espère Maxime tu nous écoutes pas mais
bon que tu préfères m'impressionner
plutôt que là je
suis pas sûr ça
donc
ok je crois que on est le prochain coup
c'est intéressant
très intéressant
F4 F3 non j'aime pas F4 F3 comme je l'ai
dit par exemple je fais tout rache 8 on
va regarder F4 le problème de F4 c'est
que ça fait bispion donc je reviens le
cavalier par exemple je viens là
il faut F3 hop là attention à ce pion
très embêtant
donc on va pas faire F4 on va pas faire
ça son idée c'est clairement d'aller
avec le cavalier ici
en F4
pourquoi des 5 ne marche pas parce que
je prends tu fais tout prendre et
regarde hop les faiblesses elles sont
encore plus voyante
et finalement on a ouvert le on a ouvert
le jeu certes parce que le roi est à
l'air de pas être en sécurité mais en
fait non parfaite sécurité ici
un petit fou G2 ouais
pour ça serait drôle ça fougère
j'aime bien
j'aime bien fouger deux non non c'est
pas bête du tout j'ai pensé j'ai posé le
proposer oui je suis timide
bouger d'eux et intéressant franchement
faut que j'ai deux c'est un truc qui se
regarde
drôle je vois pas très bien comment
tu as profite ça qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
il a joué tourage G8 Vincent donc il
considère que bon ben plus jamais de F4
ok mais la tour sur une semi ouverte
c'est ça qui a plus jamais de F4 du coup
la pluie à y penser bon là je vous donne
du disque contre sur cavalhe 3 quand
même
parce que c'était vraiment l'idée
discontin qui prend les paris
qui prend les paris sur le disque entre
et regardez-moi ça regardez la main et
hop cavalier H3 jouer par Maxime va chez
Lagrave je connais comme si je l'avais
fait
ouf
alors quel est l'âge 3
on va voir
moi Antoine G33 tu as perdu
j'aime pas
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il fait
est-ce qu'il y a une idée concrète
derrière je la vois pas son idée en tout
cas peut-être que G6 pour empêcher mais
que je vais avoir un
c'est pas clair ça fasse quelque chose
et joue ces 6 films
OK
a priori ça sera nul
après oui ça sera nul oui mais les
blancs poussent donc c'est pas je me
sens mieux
c'est une évidence alors pas pour la
jauge
ce que je vous dise moi mais les blancs
c'est clair que c'est les blancs si vous
voulez le problème de cette évaluation
0-0 ou égal ça prend pas en compte le la
probabilité de faire des erreurs il y a
beaucoup plus de de probabilité de faire
des erreurs ou de d'avoir des questions
auxquelles il va falloir répondre avec
les Noirs plutôt qu'avec les blancs donc
ça prend pas en compte ça du tout
ça c'est quand même un problème
donc parce que effectivement stockfish
il prend pas en compte qui va faire les
erreurs vu qu'il en fait pas
je suis dans le public t'inquiète ouh là
j'aime pas trop ton pseudo t'inquiète je
vais j'arrive dans le public
avec les pendus et tout je vous ai fait
un truc
aujourd'hui
j'ai kiffé bon allez les pendules sont
pas bien alignés mais ça arrive ça
arrive je suis dans le public je
retourne dans le public dès qu'ils ont
moins de 5 minutes je retourne un public
il fait roi B7 Vincent il sait pas trop
quoi faire il attend il attend de voir
ok sur quel âge 5 il va simplement
protéger et c'est vrai faut avouer hein
ça reste ça reste très très solide pour
les Noirs il s'enflamme pas il joue fou
des trois et gamer joue à 6 on met tous
les pions sur noir ça y est
l'opération
est terminée tout sur noir donc va
falloir trouver une autre pièce que le
footcaste blanche pour attaquer les
pions noirs
donc notre pièce c'est soit le cavalier
soit une tour mais pas évident vous
voyez par exemple le pion F6 a l'air
faible comment on fait concrètement pour
l'attaquer alors on peut l'attaquer
certes j'attaque une fois ok très bien
je défends et maintenant là pour
l'attaquer la deuxième fois bonne chance
et en plus quel âge 5 il y a peut-être
un problème tactique il faut prendre je
sais pas mais en tout cas peut-être qui
est 6 il faut calculer là
faut calculer tu aurais fait encore mais
enfin bon on a pas du tout envie de
faire ça avec les Blancs
alors faut que Maxime me trouve un plan
et il joue F5 ok ok faut F5 amélioration
de la pièce pourquoi pas peut-être aussi
se fout des cinq et essayer d'échanger
les fous
ça peut être pas mal parce que c'est
vrai que ce foot casse blanche
finalement il n'y a pas trop d'utilité
pour les blancs c'est peut-être la pire
pièce justement
peut-être c'est la pièce qu'on a qu'on a
envie d'échanger
et on voit pas très bien et il joue
aussi on voit son côté très pratique de
Maxime la 750 contre 3,25 il met la
pression au temps aussi très important
3 fait 800 peut-être pour plus tard
je pense qu'il faut le préparer
et le préparer en deux temps à mon avis
les coûts de préparation c'est peut-être
échanger si votre caisse blanche et
aussi mettre gamer mal au temps
il faut 4 direct était une option aussi
il joue à 4 oui
alors ça j'ai pas du tout vu venir
cahier des 5 pour attaquer ici
et en fait ce qu'il est en train de dire
c'est sur foumpion prend je vais faire
passer la tour et attention ton pion
peut être faible très intéressant
très intéressant ce coup de cahier des 5
ok j'ai pas eu tout vu venir vous voyez
c'est pour ça que je suis pas en train
de jouer là-bas
j'aime bien
ça c'est les coûts les meilleurs c'est
les coups qu'on a pas vu et quand on les
voit on se dit ah c'est pas mal ça fait
mal au moral quand on est en face je
peux vous le dire
gamer je suis pas sûr qu'il avait vu
venir ce truc
à 4 à 4 c'est pour empêcher des B3 c'est
un coup de ça paraît être un coup utile
on sait jamais dans un avenir
lointain par des tours B3 ça peut être
un coup utile mais bon c'est vrai que ça
empêche de mentir encore il donne de fou
quand même et il fait quel F3 pour faire
pour aller en D4 finalement utiliser
cette belle case en D4 et on voit
simplement deux 36 contre 7,50 pour
gamer
F3 qui est des 4 ok c'est
je vois pas trop franchement parce que
ça me laisse quand même venir à la tour
recette Cake des 4
non il a joué tout au 4 maximum
et il sacrifie la qualité waouh
et prendre la tour il a déjà un pion et
les colonnes sont fermées si tout revu
tu auras fou aussi sur les considère ok
à tout tu auras pas levier pour ouvrir
des colonnes si je prends le deuxième
pion et bien je suis je suis très très
bien
et a priori je prends un deuxième parce
qu'après toi à 8 il y a fout des 7
menace sous ces 6 mètres donc ça fait
deux pions pour la qualité plus des
colonnes fermées il considère que c'est
très très bien pour lui sans sans
hésiter oui c'est assez énorme
c'est assez énorme ce qui nous fait
Maxime Vacher La Grave allez on va on va
passer à ce moment-là je vais mettre
dans le public et on va et on regarde la
pendule vous voyez la pendule 8 0 7
contre 2 0 600 les alignés parce
qu'après je vais me faire je vais me
faire gronder sinon et regardez on va
aligner ça on va aligner ça tout de
suite et vous voyez le temps
le temps des deux joueurs
voilà le temps les deux joueurs donc on
voit le temps de gamer qui défile
et le temps de Maxime qui est là
il se lève Maxime machin aggrave alors
on va essayer de l'aligner un peu plus
un peu mieux
voilà je crois que c'est parfaitement
aligné une 29 pour gamer qui est dans le
dur et 8,07 pour Maxime est-ce que je
suis là dans le public vous me voyez je
vais me rapprocher de tout ça je vais
mettre là mettre première rang voilà à
côté de notre ami
voilà c'est un pote
il y a un incrément de 10 secondes il y
a un incrément de 10 secondes donc on
s'enflamme pas ça veut pas dire qu'il va
perdre dans le temps
mais
je vais
alors il a joué quoi gamer sur Tours
il a
jouécis et oui et c'est d'avoir du jeu
c'est si jouer je vous mette les cookies
des fines là hop là la position on vient
dans un instant C6 jouer par gamer il
essaye d'ouvrir des colonnes évidemment
quand on a une qualité de plus il faut
essayer d'ouvrir des colonnes
c'est quasi pas possible de perdre
autant avec un crayon de 10 secondes
tout à fait tout à fait c'est ça c'est
tout à fait ça
à ce niveau là ça arrive très très
rarement parce que 10 secondes c'est
quand même matelas très confortable
c'est 6 qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce
qu'on prend d'abord et on encaisse ici
où est-ce qu'on laisse ce qu'on joue un
coup de feu 4 pour essayer de fermer les
essayer de fermer la colonne il faut
aussi se peut être attaque la tour et
après on pourra prendre du fou alors
tourbé 4 échec aussi et tu entends
énormément de couper très tentant si 52
contre une 16
c'est assez dur là pour pour gamer
ouais
faut aussi s'intéressant il faut aussi
moi j'aime bien comme ça on est sûr
d'encaisser le
et ensuite on voit mais bon on va voir
ce qu'il va choisir
Maxime
on voit qui réfléchit
ouais est-ce qu'elle est spectateurs
endormi dans sa police il y a rien de
plus désagréable quand vous jouez que
vous et vous voyez quelqu'un en premier
rang qui dort
c'est vraiment c'est le pire
je préfère deux qui papotes quoi que
plutôt un
plutôt que deux qui dort pardon
alors
Maxime qui prend son temps à face
technique ça j'aime bien quand même il
se pressent pas trop
et voilà quand les choses à calculer
mais il s'arrête pour les calculer
et il joue puis on prend ces 6 échecs OK
OK
on reprend ses 6 jouer et tu reprends un
4 deux pions passés liés pour Maxime
Vacher La Grave et deux pions pour la
qualité pour Maxime et bien écoutez
c'est quand même pas mal avec des
colonnes bon maintenant c'est ouvert
mais oui c'est ouvert il en profite
gamer qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire il veut
descendre par là et obtenir du
contre-jeu évidemment évidemment qui
veut du contre je
comment on va faire Maxime avec sa
technique on rappelle un Maxime qui a
quand même une très très belle technique
peut-être pour F4 celui de fou des trois
quelque chose comme ça pour défendre et
attaquer moi j'aime bien et tout F4
jouer par Maxime va chez Lagrave
et oui si les conseils de Tonton de
Tonton Fraisse
c'est bien on protège et on attaque on
fait ça
tout F4 très bien joué de la part de
Maxime ça serait un
ça serait ça serait beau hein de gagner
cette partie parce que non seulement ça
fait qu'il sera en tête sur et en plus
gamer a 2 sur 3 donc les deux joueurs
sont en tête donc ça élimine un
concurrent dangereux ça c'est limite pas
complètement mais bon
c'est quand même c'est quand même sympa
ouais F4 tout ça c'est une très belle
opération au niveau du classement oh là
là moi je vois fout des trois j'aurais
tellement fou des trois tous les jours
ici
et fou des trois jouets par Maxime
Vacher la grave qui s'organise on fait
comment maintenant parce que non
seulement on a deux pions ils ont les
blancs en deux pions pour la qualité
mais les pions sont faibles
et t'aurais fuites obligé de jouer les
coups comme ça et maintenant vas-y que
alors je sais pas comment il faut
s'organiser et il joue B4 Maxime machine
agrave
il a bien raison il y a bien raison de
jouer B4 comment on fait ici surtout à 8
on a même on a même à 4 sur 38 parce que
tu reprends un 4 il y a B5 et regardez
cette tour qui est magnifiquement bien
placé en F4
compliqué
il essaie de créer du contrôleur ils
sont très fort en défense c'est ce
joueur là il y a pas de problème avec 30
secondes pour un A4 blitzer par Maxime
va chez Lagrave et vas-y que je te l'ai
pousse ensemble évidemment qu'il va les
pousser ensemble Maxime beaucoup trop
d'expérience et beaucoup trop de
technique pour foncer avec un pion et
oublier l'autre en les pousse ensemble
et puis on passe lié
on va gagner là c'est sûr ouais on est
pas mal on est pas mal moi je vous le
dis
un petit coup de la 5
est-ce qu'on les pousse normalement
normalement les pouces sur la couleur
opposé du Fou donc plutôt à 5 oh au
réflexe c'est à 5
patient il y a un peu de calcul qui
rentre en compte
il veut faire roi des 6 hein
et pourtant faut pousser je crois
il prend son temps j'aime bien j'aime
bien son temps il est parfois trop vite
je dirais quand ça reste ces
connaissances d'ouverture et début du
milieu de jeu mais bon c'est un temps
qui lui est très utile à la fin et qui
permet de mettre une pression maximale
sur ses adversaires donc c'est dur de
c'est une autre critiquer
ouais ouais ça fait plaisir évidemment
de voir Maxime comme ça et je joue à 5
c'est le cours réflexe à 5 rois des 6 je
vous l'avais dit voilà je trouve tous
les coups en finale milieu de jeu je
trouve pas un coup final je trouve tous
les coups
c'est comme ça pas tout avoir
alors roi des 6 et maintenant
maintenant c'est pas clair ouais B5
on n'aime pas trop qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire Maxime je suis curieux tiens il
fait à 6 ouais il pousse et il va faire
il va faire baisser 5 ensuite il veut
pas donner à casser 5 tout de suite et
sur 5 maintenant il fait baisser 5 et il
pousse par là et là ça va être terminé
donc à 6 jouer de toute façon il y a pas
traîner sa seconde pour Vincent gamer
il faut jouer maintenant
il faut jouer et il a joué quand vous
voyez un léger décalage de trois
secondes par rapport à la pendule tours
c'est un échec
de quel côté va-t-on ah j'irai plutôt en
des deux moi mais bon
[Musique]
plutôt en des deux comme ça il y a pas
il y a pas d'embrouille avec des
clouages mais bon peut-être que B2 est
bon aussi
je sais pas c'est une affaire de goût
chez parois des deux quoi que ça donne
tout un roi des deux peut-être trois B2
pour pas donner tout un roi des deux
tours j'aime pas trop ça peut donner des
échecs par là ça peut être pénible
allez Maxime qui est en train de
calculer évidemment
qui est très fort dans un genre de
position pourquoi pas en D4 c'est pas
bête peut-être tomber un quand même
pourquoi pas j'ai pas pensé tomber un B5
ou la c'est une gaffe à tomber un pardon
il faut prendre ou là ok
grave ok
tourner un jouet
pardon pardon je mets des pièces en
prises
ça y est déjà foutez
j'aime pas donner toi
très honnêtement peut-être qu'au roi des
quatre était mieux honnêtement
ouais je veux dans ma volonté de passer
la tour par là j'avais oublié que la
casbérien contrôlé donc ça sera à 1 ou
rien c'est pour ça qu'il a joué roi B2
comment il va faire Maxime ici
je me lève je me lève du public mais je
je reviens dans 5 secondes et joue ton
F3 Maxime va chez Lagrave ok il protège
son fou
je vous garantis du public indien il
fait très très chaud il fait très très
chaud dans la salle donc on va on va
ouvrir la fenêtre tout F3 ouais on
protège tout ça ouais c'est pas mal ça
et surtout des dons à faire quoi
il a joué quoi il a joué Roissy 7 et oui
il est obligé d'aller s'occuper des
pions avec le roi
ok maintenant comment on continue cette
tour vous voyez qui est passive à
souhait ça c'est quand même beau
ça fait plaisir
donc 15 secondes simplement de 50 alors
il le rattrape petit à petit mais c'est
bien c'est bien
roi ces trois jouets
tours il va faire roi des quatre
maintenant et il va attaquer spion il va
gagner un tempo
5 secondes
ou alors il a joué avec deux secondes
il a joué avec deux secondes gamer tour
B8 qui apparemment une gaffe pourquoi et
si je prends le pion là c'est cadeau ça
c'est complètement terminé il y a B5 qui
arrive et il y aura un autre pion aussi
en prise ça fait déjà ça fait trois
pions voir 4 bientôt
des k3c2 était joué tout 1 et maintenant
vas-y je te pousse le petit train
vas-y je te pousse le titre et oui tout
est protégé B5 tourbes 6 oh ça donne
presque envie de prendre par là et
d'envoyer d'envoyer les cousins par là
non mais il va garder sa tour les trois
actif ça tournef 7 certainement va être
joué
tout F7 jouets roi des 6
c'est complètement gagnant et maintenant
vas-y allez allez Maxime pousse moi ça
ou roi B2 peut-être pour essayer de
attention on peut pas sortir de la
colonne avec cette tour parce qu'il y a
allez roi B2 ça a l'air pas mal roi B2
quand même j'aime bien ah ouais je tombe
dans le seul piège mais quel andouille
mais calendrier je vous le dis moi oh là
là vraiment il est jamais trop tard pour
ne pas gagner une partie d'échec
ah il voulait jouer mais il voulait
mettre la main je pense sur roi B2 je
pense qu'il a vu le truc
donc je sais pas c'est pas
caractéristique en tout cas de rater ce
genre de choses de la part de Maxime
allez Maxime
donc pas sur la colonne B s'il te plaît
pas ça peut-être fou c'est 4 pour faire
roi des trois des choses comme ça ou
alors pour commencer à pousser pourquoi
pas
franchement si on dit que si on pousse
on n'est pas en train de s'éventer une
ville c'est vraiment la réalité il joue
à cette ouh là menace fous de 4 ok archi
concret de la part de Maxime
machinagrave où j'aime bien ce coup
attention ça pose une vraie question là
attention et oui je l'ai pas vu en fait
à 7 tout simplement poussé moi ça
poussez moi ça bien joué Maxime
bien jouer Maxime évidemment à cette
fois 4 qui va arriver on va mettre ces
dames c'est lui ça et ça va être une
victoire je crois pour Maxime Vacher la
grave je crois qu'on se dirige vers une
victoire du joueur français 14 secondes
pour Gamer pour trouver une solution
impossible la jauge qui montre
l'avantage décisif pour les blancs
et Maxime machin est grave qui va
prendre la tête du tournoi c'est quasi
certain roi aussi jouer tour à 7 va être
automatique c'est jouer ton RC3 E5
contre cette case F4 moi j'avais pensé
F4 va être joué à mon avis roi des cinq
encore mais peut-être tout recettes que
ce soit quelque chose comme ça menace
fouille 4 encore
ça a l'air fini de chez fini
allez Maxime
parce que quand même même si c'est un
tournoi alors effectivement ça qualifie
pas pour les candidats c'est du rapide
c'est du bled mais ça met en confiance
il y a rien à faire pour trouver la
confiance il faut gagner des parties
donc c'est important pour la suite de sa
carrière pour la suite du tournoi de sa
carrière il joue F3 pour jouer feu 4 il
se prouve qu'il peut battre des joueurs
de ce calibre
échec alors où est-ce qu'on va où est-ce
qu'on va peut-être 3 V3 quand même on va
mettre 4 3 C4 peut arriver aussi
et on voit qu'il meurt qui a l'air qui a
l'air résigné
trois jouets tourin et roi BK vas-y que
je t'avance le roi le fou qui va venir
là on adore on adore comme Maxime jouer
comme ça
fin technicien Maxime comme à son
habitude grosse partie je vous l'avais
dit que la finale était plus confortable
pour les blancs même l'ordinateur il
peut être tous les zéro du monde ça
reste une partie entre deux top joueurs
alors aussi fort soit-il ils font quand
même des erreurs ça arrive parfois
heureusement ça nous rassure sinon ça
serait pas très marrant
est-ce que Maxime a fait une erreur dans
la game non moi je trouve qu'il a très
très bien joué honnêtement
Maxime qui prend la tête on va faire
est-ce qu'on regardera jabboard c'est
quoi les parties marrantes alors là il y
a
Abdou Satana c'était une partie vraiment
que je voulais absolument voir et on va
regarder on va aller voir à d'où ça
torov programmer parce que là c'est
quand même un combat des chefs et
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette partie
là
qui est en train de l'emporter là il
fait des canaux technique il va
faire dames au prochain coup
voilà c'est bien je vais vous prendre
quatre ça va abandonner chez Abdou
attention
très très sérieux
et il fait dame est-ce qu'il y a une
forteresse pour les blancs on ne croit
pas aux forteresse j'étais payé pendant
10 ans pour ne pas croire au forteresse
je n'ai pas le droit de croire au
forteresse on est comme Magnus Carlsen
on n'y croit pas
allez
ça ne marche pas les forteresses tourner
5 ouh ça va mal se termine quand même
cette histoire chez un ordi bec
cette tour qui peut être prise à
n'importe quel moment
il joue au roi j'ai 6 au final il va la
gagner cette partie moi je vous le dis
ouais il est pas au milieu de sa forme
mais bon
Magnus Carson ne croit pas forteresse on
le sait c'est connu
tu crois pas au forteresse et là on y
croit vraiment pas c'est une forteresse
en carton il faudrait qu'il y ait un
truc stable pour pour la au moins la
tour là le roi coupé mais même ça ça
suffirait pas on pourrait être en
exemples
donc les forteresses avec la tour qu'on
de la dame c'est quand même assez rare
d'amser un il a pas d'air inquiet le
jeune Prague il a dû voir qu'il y aura
ramasser la tour au moins le purger
là c'est une faible race va juste au TV
ouais tu as tout à fait raison tout à
fait allez on va aller voir une autre
voir la victoire de Prague ici
et victoire de gris de chou enfin c'est
réglée ça fait plaisir représentant
digne représentant de ma génération
et peut-être visite contre gouquettes
allons voir vite contre gouquettes ça
sera plus passionnant
allez on va aller voir ça
alors visite contre goûter
et visite qui bat son jeune homologue
indien
il est en train de battre avec Dame
cavalier contre une pièce de plus
simplement pour visite on va voir la
réalisation ouais il encaisse le pion
et que ça se bat encore chez Google qui
est quand même qui est dans le dur
depuis le début
il est dans le dur
ok en difficulté quasi tout le temps
je vois pas alors la seule chance ne se
laisse pas pour les Noirs c'est
évidemment pour les blancs pardon pour
les Noirs c'est que le roi est très loin
et donc d'échanger les dames et
d'arriver à avec le roi allez prendre
ses pions et il fait Dame des cinq là il
joue plus Mister chess 67 qui me demande
tu es toujours sur grande magnitude par
partie classique donc c'est compliqué
j'ai toujours été secondaire pour les
parties classiques donc comme il y a
plus et bien
vraiment
mais bon ça reste cinq matchs champion
du monde quand même
pensez pas durer autant honnêtement même
ces trois échec jouer par Vidy 3b6 et
maintenant on va essayer gentiment de
ramener le cavalier par là je suppose
tout en évitant les perpétuels et de
ramener le roi par là
et oui j'étais secondaire pour tous les
matchs le seul entraîneur va participer
à tous les matchs donc depuis 2013 à
Chennai
c'est quoi un second danseur
on appelle ça secondant en
terme échiquier 1 seconde dans le second
voilà du champion
voilà dame 2 pourquoi a-t-il écrasé la
concurrence
une X
tellement de raisons mais la la
moi je dirais que la plus grande raison
c'est c'est sa volonté ça rage de
vaincre en toute circonstance et ce truc
au moment clutch le fameux mot en clutch
le moment décisif
toujours de gagner de gagner de gagner
de gagner de jamais se reposer de
toujours gagner
de jamais être satisfait d'une victoire
toujours se remettre en question
toujours essayer même dans les moments
où c'est très bien joué c'est tout est
très bien fait toujours essayer de de
faire mieux et ça je crois que c'est une
mentalité de
très très grands champions
il y avait quand même secondaire pendant
à l'année on était deux avec Peter
de 3 à 5 en passant par 4 ça dépend des
alors on voit visite il va il va quand
même l'emporter et
ça paraît quand même
plus que difficile là pour pour goûter
de sauver ça
il va falloir revenir il y a plus
d'échecs donc faut revenir avec la dame
elle joue quand
Jesse hello 23
j'ai très peu de secondaire j'ai une
fois Richard à portes et comme dit quand
il était très jeune mais c'était assez
marrant très très utile
Richard importe qui avait 16 ans et qui
me secondait pendant tout un tournoi en
ça sent le ça sent le roussi là pour
pour caisse plus que le Roussil c'est
fini quasiment mais qu'est-ce qui se bat
ce jeune joueur
par contre la bonne chance
Dame des 7 ok il y a toujours pas de
fourchette
parce que et s'il est tombé et vous
voyez et vous voyez il est tombé
l'ami la Migou Kech est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres est-ce qu'il y a d'autres cam
est-ce qu'il se passe autre chose
non c'est terminé pour cette ronde mais
pas du tout
pour le tournoi on va voir et regarder 5
résultats décisifs victoires de mvl qui
nous fait plaisir évidemment à Krishna
qui qui souffre
clairement contre Raja bof
des fêtes à fond la vue contre Prague il
a perdu grichu qui a battu Iris
ik confirme aussi sa souffrance dans ce
tournoi et vide qui bat Google a été
très bon
jusque là il pourrait être à 3 sur 4
s'il avait conclu sa partie d'hier mais
ce n'était pas le cas et qui est avec 3
sur 4 c'est Maxime va chier La Grave 3
sur 4 en tête
à jobov 3 et c'est vrai que les doyens
sont là Raja BOV gritchouk mvl et
programme da qui se met au milieu avec
deux et demi sur 4 donc rien n'est
terminé mais c'est pas mal c'est un très
très bon début de tournoi pour
Maxime va chier la grave avec trois sur
quatre on va regarder
je vais vous dire ce qu'on va regarder
on va regarder
on va regarder les
appareils de la prochaine ronde contre
qui va jouer Maxime machinagrave je
pense que ce sera à 13h
et il va jouer cookeh
on est gâté là Google qui vient de
perdre qui est vraiment dans le dur dans
ce tournoi on le reconnaît pas trop il
est quasiment foutu dans chaque partie
bon c'est dur parfois de jouer à
domicile et
on a ensuite
Eric et contre vidite Raja BOV contre
gris Chuck alors ça c'est c'est pas la
première fois qu'on voit ça c'est
vraiment un grand classique au Prague
contrarie Christina l'ancienne
génération contre la nouvelle et Vincent
gamer face à nord du bec à Dos Santos
deux joueurs qui ont perdu la première
partie qui ont à cœur de se refaire on
rappelle que Abdou cette robe champion
du monde de partir rapide en 2021
Vincent gamer vie champion du monde de
partir rapide en 2022 ça joue pas mal
quand même
alors ce que je vais faire
c'est que je vais changer en direct
parce que je me rappelle plus comment on
change on va faire une petite pause je
vais changer ce rapide jour 1 on est
bien dans le jour 2 du rapide Maxime
machine agraf et tempête la prochaine
partie peut-être avant 13h
je suis pas sûr franchement je sais pas
si c'est une pause ou si les joueurs en
fait
comment ça marche exactement je pense
que c'est 13h mais peut-être avant donc
on reviendrai avant je prends une petite
cette huile de pause et je reviens je
vais essayer de mettre
le rapide jour 2 en
grand et voilà je vous remercie de me
suivre et je reviens je reviens je reste
je reste pour cette folle journée où on
pourrait voir Maxime la Chaira virer
seul en tête pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas à tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus à du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title Tuss
day.com/aventu vous voulez streamer des
échecs comme vos créateurs préférés tels
que bin stream Naka ou les soeurs
le programme de Community streamer de
cheese.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience vous connectant
votre compte à cheese.com et profiter de
la visibilité offerte alors notre
plateforme de jeu il vous suffit de
relier votre compte à
cheese.com/ettings
mettre échec comme catégorie sur twitch
et commencer à streamer
d'une expérience sans publicité sur
chaise.com et apparaître et dans
d'autres listes de streamers en direct
votre profites.com affichera votre
stream twitch qui sera aussi mis en
avant durant vos parties offert utiliser
la commande community streamer dans le
chat et faites grossir votre audience
sans plus attendre
[Musique]
et je suis de retour donc avec Maxime la
chaîne
et plus que jamais en tête de ce
tactile India on va regarder ça tout de
suite ça fait plaisir Maxime Vacher La
Grave 3 sur 4
très solide
belle victoire très technique
à la rente 4 face à Vincent gamer et
voilà une victoire hier contre vidite
moins technique
dans une position archi compliquée
avec une tour de moins mais il a supposé
des problèmes poser des questions
jusqu'au bout il croit jusqu'au bout et
il a emporter à la fin et il va jouer
dans quelques minutes face à Google avec
les Noirs un vrai test
mais Google en petite forme dans ce
tournoi le nouveau
numéro 1 indien
et oui il a pris la place de
il a pris la place de Vichy à Nantes
après 37 ans de règne de Vichy à Nantes
rendez-vous compte numéro 1 indien et
bien il a pris sa place
on va aller prendre la partie on voit
Maxime Vacher la draft qui aura les
noirs on va tout de suite tourner
chéquier regardez-moi ça non paramètres
qu'est-ce que je fais annuler annuler
comment ton échiquier sur cette
plateforme et bien c'est pas très
compliqué normalement je m'en souviens
plus et c'est juste là hop là comme ça
on se met du côté noir et on va faire
pareil sur le live board donc le petit
liveboard
que vous voyez
qui va être ici
au plat et on va aussi tourner les
chéquiers
Maxime va chez La Grave donc il y aura
les noirs et le redoutable privilège
d'affronter
gouquettes alors je sais pas si c'est si
ces deux joueurs là ont beaucoup joué
ensemble je pense pas
mais en tout cas on va avoir une une
belle partie une caméra qui plante ah
non et encore de grand Prague je crois
ouais ben non il est semi retraité donc
effectivement il joue plus trop et le
petit défaut le classement hello est
quand même assez bien fait mais le petit
défaut du classement hello c'est quand
on est inactif et bien on garde son
classement ce qui est pas forcément très
juste
parce que quand on est inactif
et quand on revient normalement on perd
des points donc
voilà ça tient pas en compte
ça tient pas en compte l'activité c'est
le le fait de jouer beaucoup ou pas
et effectivement c'est pour ça que un
ange aussi c'est maintenu aussi
longtemps parce que il partait de très
hauts même s'il joue encore très très
bien
ouais alors après
ouais ça dépend ça dépend le classement
et l'eau il dit quand même beaucoup de
choses sur son niveau actuel en tout cas
bien le pic de Ana on a c'est 2830 je
crois que comme ça maintenant il doit
avoir 2750
donc je crois qu'il va rejouer là en
Coupe d'Europe
il joue un petit peu de temps encore et
quand il joue attention il joue il joue
quand même pas mal
Vichy garde quand même une classe assez
incroyable
on peut regarder je peux regarder tout
de suite le classement et l'eau là 2700
chess
pour voir est-ce que
est-ce que un an on est toujours devant
Prague c'est une bonne question ah non
les numéros 9 mondial avec 2754 coupé
chez le numéro 8 avec 2758
tous beau monde est devant Maxime machin
qui a 2727 qui a perdu pas mal de points
en haut à aller au classique et praganda
et execo pile poil avec mvl à 2727 donc
encore loin de Vichy mais bon
c'est clair que le temps joue pas la
faveur de de la lande et donc a priori
Prague devrait aussi lui passer devant
ETI très probablement aussi de 1712
donc on va suivre évidemment tout ça
ouais ouais clairement clairement c'est
rassurant de voir un Maxime jouer comme
ça ouais c'est rapide mais bon c'est des
c'est de la confiance en grand j'ai
et la confiance ça ne s'achète pas
ça se gagne ça se gagne en gagnant des
parties qu'on émergeant du monde tout
simplement
les joueurs gèrent comment les prépas en
quoi de la couleur et l'adversaire il le
connaissent il y a un tirage au sort
juste avant le tournoi donc voilà ils
savent ils savent le premier jour du
tournoi en général il y a un tirage au
sort et donc ils ont plus préparer déjà
un amont avant le tournoi et ensuite ils
ont le détail donc chaque jour en
général les joueurs font une petite
prépa c'est une petite idée de ce qu'ils
vont jouer ou pas jouer
voilà donc la prépa est pas inexistante
clairement
c'est clair que Maxime c'est exactement
qu'on est le répertoire de Google
va se préparer contre gouquet au moins
un petit peu alors la prépa est plus
légère en général en partie rapide ça
joue moins sur les ouvertures et c'est
ce qui fait le charme des parties
rapides évidemment ou c'est vrai comme
manuscrit et j'ai vu la question tout à
l'heure pourquoi il a arrêté de jouer
tout simplement parce qu'il considère
qu'il y a trop de prépa dans ces matchs
du monde ça joue trop sur les ouvertures
et qu'il faudrait passer à des cadences
plus rapides tout simplement vous savez
les cadences sont pas beaucoup évolués
alors que la théorie des ouvertures a
beaucoup évolué donc par exemple
maintenant on joue c'est pas rare de
jouer les 15 20 premiers coussins
réfléchir et donc c'est vrai qu'on a le
même temps après pour jouer alors
qu'avant la théorie était beaucoup moins
évoluée donc finalement le monde a
changé et les cadences sont restés les
mêmes
je trouve ça assez logique
je pense qu'il a je pense qu'il a raison
combien en argent et on voit Google
combien en argent et on peut aller voir
ça rapidement non non je sais pas
exactement mais il y a des starting
fille je sais pas exactement mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a
des bons prix et c'est avant tout une
histoire de confiance de prestige de
gagner ce tournoi
donc clairement
clairement ces joueurs là alors
effectivement ils ont des bons prix mais
le plus important pour eux c'est quand
même de faire un bon tournoi de gagner
de la confiance pour les prochaines
échéances maximacher La Grave jouera la
Coupe d'Europe mais je vous rassure tout
le le grand Suisse à l'île de Man pour
essayer de se qualifier pour les
candidats son objectif toujours déclaré
ça reprend les travaux
mais le BTP alors à 13h c'est la pause
quand même faut s'arrêter faut arrêter
de travailler les enfants
et oui le centième c'est la France est
un top 10 ouais tout à fait
tout à fait le centième et français on
sait pas qui c'est
je suis revenu un peu plus haut et après
je suis redescendu 100e tour des quatre
jouets par
Google
a accepté garde évidemment accepté c'est
bien il change ses ouvertures il faut
être cap système de Londres ouh là là
alors là
système de Londres de la part de Google
même les jeunes jouent le système de
Londres
elle est pas sorti de l'auberge
alors E3 c'est 5 c'est sa partie contre
gris chouk pour l'instant kid2
il change goket
et maintenant sur qui c'est 6 je suppose
qu'il va faire qui est ici
Maxime il a double
alors faut faire attention aux ordres de
cou dans ce genre de choses qui est ici
c'est ce qu'il va faire ces trois non je
pense pas il va faire KF3 quand même ah
non il fait ces trois waouh ça c'est une
surprise
parce que c'est pas censé être le plus
dangereux pour les noirs
est-ce qu'on peut punir comme ça dame B6
dame B3 c'est 4 vous me direz c'est pas
si bête son truc
mais là je peux faire G6 peut-être faut
regarder G6
répertoire facile mais on s'attend
quelque chose de plus agressif d'un
jeune joueur comme booké mais bon après
tout c'est des rapides
tellement partie à jouer pourquoi pas
ces trois il joue aussi Maxime ok qui
est la grande variante évidemment KF3
et cavalier H5 Blitz C
on veut prendre le four on pouvait aussi
prendre des quatre et prendre des 4 et
jouer que les H5 mais ça c'est une autre
ligne
qui est très jouée aussi j'ai dû jouer
ça moi-même
alors la réaction typique ici c'est soit
typique la première c'est ça faut 5 sur
cavalier prend et puis on prend et ça
c'est embêtant
attention ce cavalier est mal placé donc
on provoque F6 et foug-3 ça c'est la
première réaction et la deuxième c'est
fou j'ai 5
attaque la dame et il faut que j'ai 5
jouets F6 joué par Maxime fois 4
et maintenant j'ai 6 ouais pour souvent
recycler ce cahier G7 ce cavalière H5 le
maître en G7 suit de F5 et aussi la
menace des blancs était tout simplement
de faire G2 G4 et de gagner le cavalier
donc j'ai 6 tours C1 ça c'est assez
mystérieux comme coup mais ça fait
partie de sa prépa
la mort ton C1 qui se prépare à
reprendre du pion C en cas d'échange et
d'occuper la colonne ouverte
et peut-être aussi on veut faire des
pions prend et ces quatre et essayer
d'ouvrir cette colonne quoi qu'il en
coûte
intéressant faire perdre un temps au
noir parce qu'ici le coup normal ça
serait fou au 7 mais à ce moment-là on
prendrait ici en fossette on prendra ici
et c'est vrai que les Noirs perdus du
temps donc intéressant ce petit coup de
tourco1 la profil axi à son max
salut amical très amical rikikits
Maxime Lagarde
ancien champion de France
champion de France 2019 avec beaucoup de
chance je me tuer à le répéter mais
voilà il nous suit on le salue
fouder 3 un des tous meilleurs joueurs
français depuis de nombreuses années
l'autre Maxime
qui sera je sais pas si je vois l'île de
Man aussi est-ce que le comptage en
français sera
sera avec avec Maxime Lagarde ou pas
je sais qui joue en Coupe d'Europe
mais ouais
je sais pas si il sera là-bas non pas le
niveau
il est modeste il a failli cette année
au
[Musique]
championnat de France c'était pas loin
pas loin d'une finale une troisième
place finalement qui est quand même un
résultat solide
mais moi je vais partager à couper le
souffle face à Romain Edward ou ça joue
évidemment à la fin sur les nerfs la
fatigue petit coup du sort aussi
petit truc de réussite qui fait que bah
c'est un Armageddon il y a des Blitz
voilà ça joue aussi sur ça
et il a une déclaration d'amour je
t'aime rikikit de patapoum 34
alors revenons à nos moutons tours c'est
un kg7 menace cavalier F5 donc foudet 3
logique vous êtes rock et maintenant
est-ce qu'il veut prendre et jouer ces
quatre c'est ça la question parce que
maintenant cette tour est ridicule vous
jouez ces quatre directement
il va falloir faire quelque chose en
faire en tout cas on a envie quand on
joue un coup comme tour C1 on a quand
même envie de justifier par la suite
donc maintenant Google normalement ça
devrait
ça devrait ça devrait passer
ça devrait être toujours dans sa prépa
normalement parce que là les coups les
coups de Maxime sont pas du tout
surprenants franchement
c'est des coups tout à fait standards et
logique avec les Noirs ce G6 qui est G7
et joue fougait trois d'abord alors ça
c'est encore un coup mystérieux
empêche peut-être 5 oui certes
je sais pas qui avait les H5 là
ton fou si tu reviens je reviens
j'aime bien cavalier H5 pourquoi pas
ok je sais pas franchement
ouais il y a un public alors il est pas
hyper nombreux mais on sait qu'il y
avait un vrai boom
autour des échecs joué par Maxime va
chez La Grave
bon je suppose que Google
ah oui merci de people de rappeler ça
Maxime la garde déjà amis français le
troisième meilleur joueur de ah non 4e
4e meilleur joueur de ping-pong
après Sébastien il y a une bière gros il
y a des gros défis au ping-pong
Sébastien Mazet éteint le chef
je suis le numéro 2
10 g de numéro 3
et Maxime la garde numéro 4 qui est pas
mal quand même ce qui est pas mal 4e
c'est beau
cavalier H5 puis on prend ses 5 mvl et
un style tout à fait particulier au
ping-pong il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs d'échecs qui adorent le qui
adore le ping-pong donc Maxime vacherer
probablement numéro 5 et non je suis
numéro 2 l'auto programme et Laurent non
je suis pas je suis pas trop proclamé il
y a des résultats les résultats les
chiffres sont tenaces quand on gagne des
matchs on gagne des matchs
et vous prend ces cinq est-ce qu'il va
fermer dans ces quatre ou quatre c'est
l'heure du choix a priori C4 quand même
C4 pour faire juste cette tour
E4
je bouge pas en fait je prends j'ai
trois d'abord et je fous B6 ça a l'air
quand même très raisonnable une
française très agréable pour les Noirs
pas du tout forcé mais vous voyez on a
ouvert la grande diagonale ça a pas
l'air terrible je pense que c'est 4 et
le coup et C4 et jouer par notre ami
Google
mais non on fait jouer cette tour et le
seul problème dans la position noire
c'est ce fou qui n'est pas encore sorti
sachant que sur des 4 je pense que le
décale va pas marcher à cause de Key B3
attaque le fou attaque le pion
ça a posé les petits problèmes donc si
on joue à une structure symétrique comme
ça
admettons puis on prend je prends du
cavalier ou du Fou a priori du fou je
mets un souffrant admettons un petit
coup de on prend d'abord là je prends G3
il faut B6
les noirs sont bien grâce à la paire de
fou mais il reste un léger souci
c'est le développement de se fousser
vite si on arrive à le régler on sera
pas moins bien mais c'est pas si facile
à régler par exemple disons cavalier 4
un coup comme ça on voit fouder 7 c'est
pas très agréable il y a même des 6 qui
arrive
c'est quand même des pions faibles
donc
pas si évident des petites questions
pour Maxime C4 il joue qui est projet 3
je prends G3 et fou B6 et il laisse il
prend pas en C4 donc et il laisse le
soin au blanc de faire cet échange donc
après puis on prend je suppose qu'il va
pas vouloir dame me prendre et va
vouloir puis on prend un petit pion
isolé mais largement compensé par la
paire de fou un fou qui va sortir
beaucoup plus facilement du coup
une position tout à fait raisonnable
pour les noirs
en roi G7 c'est un coup aussi hein c'est
vrai c'est un coup sur case noire qui va
certainement arriver plus tard dans la
partie mais pas tout de suite on laisse
C5 mais c'est 5 ça laisse quand même le
centre c'est à dire de gagner un tempo
mais bon cette compliqué de faire déjà
pour organiser B4 cette compliqué à
trois on va faire à 5 simplement et
ensuite on va faire le 5 on a la paire
de fou et le centre vaut mieux pas les
deux vous pouvez laisser le centre ou la
paire de fou mais la paire de fou et le
centre en général c'est ça fait mauvais
ménage
alors
merci
chessfish à bientôt
ouais j'ai réussi à mettre jour de oh
c'était pas très compliqué
mais je savais pas le faire Aurore
antenne j'ai fait pendant l'antenne
mais c'est pas grave qu'est-ce qui fait
Google et Maxime qui joue toujours aussi
vite position ouverture plutôt réussie
je dirais franchement je vois pas de
problème particulier ici pour Maxime
ouais mais on peut pas empêcher les
ah ouais mais comment tu fais comment tu
fais pour que les joueurs n'aient pas
accès aux ordis pour se préparer non
c'est pas c'est pas crédible ton idée
alors c'est une bonne idée sur le papier
mais on peut pas les enfermer les mettre
dans un loft les joueurs clairement ça
poserait quand même un petit souci ça
serait compliqué
et réfléchis Google
petite forme on le rappelle ok je crois
qu'il a un émission 4 et puis il s'en
sort bien en plus
oh là le BTP là qui me casse les
oreilles
ah le Secret Story des échecs ça serait
un concept ah bah oui moi je vais être
avec toi mon Maxou hein important je
veux absolument que tu sois si tu y vas
j'y vais et on joue au ping-pong et
c'est filmé tout ça
ça ça pourrait être drôle effectivement
des petits milieux vous savez comme
mieux échecs où tout le monde se courait
depuis très longtemps des petites
illimitives des amitiés voilà il
pourrait y avoir il pourrait y avoir
quelque chose de sympa à faire ouais
des ex
ça pourrait ça pourrait être très sympa
Maxime qui se lève fidèle à son habitude
très à l'aise
ouais ouais non mais bien sûr bien sûr
que ça fait plaisir pour Maxime
et oui my se bag qui avait fait un
apparition furtive
dans Secret Story justement
c'est pas dans son
c'était pas son truc finalement on a
décidé après quelques jours que c'est
pas son truc
pourquoi pas les gens font ce qu'ils
veulent
je sais pas comment il fait Google
c'est quoi le plan
faut faire quelque chose de très rapide
de très concret parce que si on laisse
les Noirs s'organiser et bien c'est
clair qu'ils ont pas de problème sur le
long terme avec cette belle paire de
fous
ce beau contrôle des cases noires quand
même que confère
se fout de case noire alors je sais pas
pourquoi la jauge mais 0,6 pour les
blancs je vais regarder je vais tricher
un peu pour voir ce qu'elle met la jauge
ça m'intrigue à trois à trois 0,65 pour
les blancs
après
si je fais à 5 il se passe quoi à Eddie
puis on prend puis on prend quelque
chose de très rapide on joue sur casse
blanche
mais bon même ça ça va
même ça ça va pour les noirs
je regarde la première ligne de
l'ordinateur et la roche G7 OK
à peu près équilibré
donc pas d'inquiétude par rapport à la
jauge qui montre quand même une variante
assez obscure pour les blancs
et Maxime toujours qui prend son petit
matelas il arrête pas de bâiller par
contre ça c'est un peu plus inquiétant
mais
clairement
il prend une petite avance au temps là
un petit matelas confortable
et pas évident mais c'est vrai que à
trois finalement quand on y a pas grand
chose à faire pour les blancs à moins
que ça soit il réfléchisse à ça
directement
qui est pas idiot en fait d'essayer
d'ouvrir le jeu tant que ce le problème
du Fou de casse blanche n'est pas
n'est pas résolu mais le problème c'est
qu'on peut on peut le résoudre comme ça
et on va reprendre du Fou évidemment on
laisse les blancs prendre en dessin
ah oui c'est la fiche de prochain speech
il en reste Google chez et Maxime c'est
bien possible on l'appelle le speech qui
aura lieu ces trois prochaines semaines
sur cheesecom je crois que c'est la miss
touffe qui va qui s'y colle
et voilà vous pouvez regarder le
[Musique]
les live évidemment speechez qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est le droit decescom ou
très beau format moi j'ai toujours adoré
ce format très très honnêtement du 5 +
1h30
une heure de trois plus un et 30 minutes
de 1 + 1
donc voilà du Blitz on n'a pas le temps
de s'ennuyer il y a des il y a des
retombantes situations alors pour
l'instant c'est avec les matchs il y a
une Camorra yoongi et soit rognan ou
c'est vrai que les premiers tours ça
peut tourner au vinaigre pour les moins
forts et ça a été le cas
Magnus je sais pas contre qui joue mais
il y aura les raisins aussi en fait
c'est quand même c'est quand même
un très très beau plateau clairement
c'est keV quand même mvl et
fil rouge ou qui commande je crois ouais
c'est possible c'est possible
je sais pas du tout je suis pas au
courant du truc de chaise de du
programme de cheescom
sur ça en français mais oui c'est
possible
c'est possible qu'il commente les
les
speechs avec mvl ou Ali resa ou Magnus
ou Naka je sais pas exactement
comment ça
je suis pas au courant honnêtement
de ce qui se passe mais oui
effectivement Kevin a commenté le la
Coupe du Monde et aime bien de temps en
temps enfin même assez régulièrement
commenté sur cheescom ou sur sa chaîne
les grands événements
avec les Français ou Magnus
alors
puis on prend des 5 puis on prend des 5
et B3 on joue sur le remettre en quart
de calme c'est pas très impressionnant
il jouera j'essaie je vous l'avais dit
qu'il allait arriver ce coup-là
clairement
le speechester trois prochaines semaines
allez voir le calendrier sur le
cheesecom il y a ou suivez-nous sur les
réseaux sociaux ne n'hésitez pas surtout
à nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
X ou Twitter comme vous voulez Facebook
aussi abonnez-vous aux chaînes twitch
YouTube ou que vous soyez ou comme ça
vous chante ce que vous préférez mais
abonnez-vous ça coûte rien c'est un
petit pouce et ça vous permet de ne rien
rater
voilà c'est à dire qu'après vous avez
une petite notif qui vous dit ah ben il
y a le chaud avec machin qui commente
machin
ça vous plaît vous regardez ça vous
plaît pas vous regardez pas vous avez le
choix
alors il a joué Dame des 6 MD2 et
maintenant c'est l'heure de la sortie du
four
je vais sortir avant moi pour être
honnête hein j'aurais fait un petit coup
de petit coup de fougère peut-être
mesdames des 6 un bon coup on joue sur
case noire on empêche KFC 5 il avait
certainement peur de ça à mon avis il
avait peur d'un truc comme ça et c'est
vrai que on est chatouillé sur B7 c'est
jamais très agréable donc il joue Dame
des 6 d'abord empêchant ce genre de truc
Dame des deux
et
maintenant que va-t-il faire
et bien a priori il va sortir son fou
ou maintenant
attention les blancs veulent jouer tour
D1 et attaquer espion c'est aussi simple
que ça et aussi bête que ça il faut
aussi ces jouable il faut aussi c'est
complètement jouable on peut le cacher
ici ensuite tourner 8 et on est pas mal
j'aime bien
surtout que vous avez des trucs comme ça
admettons cahier des quatre même se
permettre je pense on peut prendre
évidemment
mais se permettre des pions pendant donc
les pions pendant c'est ça
les pions qui n'ont pas de rivaux en
face mais qui sont isolés en fait ils
pendent
et là il me semble qu'avec la paire de
fou ça peut quand même donner un truc
sympa
donc faut aussi je me semble très bien
et il faut aussi jouer par mvl
qui vient d'arriver à la même conclusion
que nous
que c'est un coup bien solide
bien sûr
docteur bilbaz qui dit
salut d'abord cher ami est-ce que j'ai
un compte sur cheescom j'ai un compte
depuis très très longtemps
Zlatan 56
le même je l'avais j'avais mon compte
avant d'avoir un compte chez N4 c'est
vrai que j'ai pas utilisé pendant
plusieurs années et je jouais le
champions de la Division 2
il y a pas si longtemps donc avec
beaucoup de c'est un très beau format un
champion de chaise tour qui a été repris
par repris et améliorée j'ai envie de
dire
élargi par tchécom c'est à dire qu'il y
a plus simplement les 8 10 meilleurs et
moi ça m'arrange il y a aussi des moins
bons en division 2 en division 3 donc
j'ai joué une fois division 3 une fois
division 2 et voilà avec beaucoup de
plaisir de jouer c'est rapide
c'était le bon vieux temps
joué par Maxime comme comme je vous
l'avais dit on n'a pas peur de cahier
français on est très confort ici
alors placement moi je sais pas répond à
toutes ces questions
c'est fini je suis un simple
[Musique]
avant je décidais un minimum
c'est fini ce temps là
maintenant je dis ce je fais ce qu'on me
dit de faire et de dire
bon je me rebeller un petit peu je
faisais le malin fini
donc je sais pas ce qui est prévu ce qui
est pas prévu
le mug chaise 24 bien sûr
les enfants
je sais pas à la boutique à mon avis
elle est fermée de chaise 24
marche plus
donc ceux qui l'ont eu sont les chances
alors il met ses tours au centre très
logique kevd 4 on a envie de faire
pareil
pour C8 me sens tellement naturel
c'est dur de pas jouer ton switch je
trouve
si play manus a été racheté
de faut suivre les commandes de la
Bourse c'est paye Magnus a acheté pas
que bon tout un tas de trucs
et ensuite plague Magnus a été racheté
par chaise comme
donc du coup tu sais ce qu'on va pas
racheter 24 cheesecom a racheté play
Magnus mais comme chaises 24 faisait
partie de Play Magnus bah voilà
vous avez compris l'histoire
ah il y a toujours le shop il est il est
ouvert
réponse fournie très public
bien joué bien vu bien vu bien vu
c'est pour ça qu'il l'a pas fait et
qu'il a joué qui est le 5 passer pour ça
que ouais ton C8 j'aurais pas vu fouger
4 tiens très embêtant fougère et sur F5
c'est le coup qu'on a envie de jouer il
y a fou point F5 à mon avis qui attaque
ici évidemment on peut jamais prendre il
y a la fourchette si on recommence à
faire des coups intermédiaires ça se
passe mal parce qu'il faut prendre donc
ça va pas
et donc Maxime joue cavalier 5 coûte
très logique aussi quand on le voit on
peut aller là on contrôle la case on va
mettre une petite tour en C8 on est très
très bien c'est bon pour Maxime tout ça
ils ont tendance que ça chez com mais
apparemment
apparemment c'est pas grave
vous pouvez voir le prix je sais plus
comment c'était mais 80 millions de
dollars je sais pas combien
c'est dommage que j'avais pas j'aurais
bien aimé être propriétaire de playmag
mais du coup ça m'arranger cette
histoire à 80 millions
mais voilà bon écoutez en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que à titre personnel
et je pense que c'était une volonté
globale j'étais très bien accueilli par
nos amis de cheescom donc ça fait
plaisir
et non malheureusement
si j'avais été propriétaire j'aurais
jamais vendu tu me connais mal docteur
mille basse ça dépend du prix
alors A4 il fait à 4 pour faire à 5 à 5
à tempo par mvl il fait pas marcher
dessus
ouais alors je sais pas comment ça
marche exactement
pour être pour être honnête
donc à 4 à 5 c'est quand même de bien de
on va revenir à nos moutons quand même
parce que c'est quand même une bonne je
trouve c'est une bonne inclusion pour
les blancs pourquoi parce que ce pion à
5 va être faible admettons je passe mon
tour qu'est-ce qu'on joue avec les
Blancs ici je tourne ces deux par
exemple et surtout assez vite c'est vrai
qu'il y a toujours ce pion regardez un
œil parce que ce pion sent beaucoup plus
dur à attaquer on pourra toujours mettre
un fou ici donc à 4 et un bon coup
à 4 à 6 le problème c'est qu'il y avait
à 5 fois 7 je suppose et ensuite c'est
vrai qu'il y a des il y a
potentiellement alors pas tout de suite
mais potentiellement des incursions sur
la colonne c'est ce qui peut être
désagréable donc à 4 est un bon coup une
belle question de la part de Google j'ai
prévu par Maxime
qui a toujours ses 4 minutes d'avance on
est bien on est pas mal c'était pas mal
son truc mais
Google mais Maxime a répondu sans
vraiment il a pas cligné des yeux il a
joué à 5 à tempo il avait tout vu il
semble très très en forme la vie Maxime
et peut-être qu'il veut faire qu'elle
essaie 4 ah non ok c'est 4 contre un des
bêtises surtout ces deux on va voir
pourquoi qui est C4 n'est pas une menace
parce qu'il y a en C4 pions
penser 4 et cavalier F5 je montre que je
suis alerte tactiquement à Maxime
Lagarde qui nous regarde et dès que je
fais une gaffe
il fait il m'en parle après
et regardez on perd la dame donc et ces
quatre n'est pas une menace
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec les
noirs on a aussi des petits plans comme
tour à F8 H5 H4 si on veut s'inventer
une vie essayer de mater
bon ça me semble quand même
questionnable ce genre de choses
il joue qui avait les F3 ok ok
non pardon il joue à 4 à 5 cavaliers F3
bon je change pas grand chose
un coup étonnant en tout cas je suis
étonné
je vois pas trop ce qu'on veut faire
parce qu'on veut jamais vraiment prendre
ici parce qu'il y a on va reprendre du
pion on aura un très très beau centre et
puis isolé
donc ça semble
fou 8 il y aura ce pion là mais il y a
ce pion là alors faut vite c'est un
petit peu j'aime pas
j'aime pas au feeling peut même
peut-être fou B5 et ce fou quand même
alors certes il est pas bon j'aime pas
du tout mais
certes
ce pion attaque non mais on a envie de
défendre ce pion quand même avec le fou
alors effectivement c'est pas sa
position la plus active mais on a quand
même envie de garder le contrôle de ça
parce que par exemple sur faut 8
admettons je fais tourner bêtement
il me semble qu'on va quand même être
obligé de revenir en F7 pour protéger le
pion
donc
oui mais les tours là c'est l'heure
et toi
c'est l'heure de mettre la tour au
centre et oui et de garder le contrôle
de ce de ce pion à 5 que faire goûter
maintenant
c'est là où j'avais pas la ref
-3 d'accord ok à 4 d'accord et
maintenant comment on fait pour
continuer à essayer de poser des
questions
maintenant fou C4 est plus toujours
possible
non non
cavalier prend puis on prend un fou
c'est 4 ça perd
pourquoi ça perd
voilà
à la fin
tous ces quatre perdant et ben
Maxou aide-moi je vois pas pourquoi
je vois pas
je la vois pas la tactique je la vois
pas je veux un coup de dames c'est nul
coup de dames comme ça c'est ça le coup
comme ça attaque le fou c'est vrai qu'on
menacerait en fait on menace pas faut
prendre des cinq en fait et surtout B5
on attaque ici on menaçant c'est terminé
bon c'est complètement random cette
variante évidemment qui est prend le 5
va
à moins qu'il y ait vraiment quelque
chose
de très concret ça sera jamais joué
jouer par Google mais ça libère cette
tour donc on peut en profiter
immédiatement en jouant la tour en C8
serait quand même un coup archiologique
dans mes maximes il habite c'est un
autre coup il a joué qui est ici
aussi tout va bien pour les Noirs le
balai des cavaliers là regardez le
cavalier qui vient F3 puis en D4 et puis
simplifier finalement il vient il va là
il a fait quelle idée de quai B3 kf3d4
cavalier D4 F3 et qui est B3 D4 bon on a
vu plus impressionnant en conséquence
quand même tour C3 ok ok ok on veut
doubler et oui oui bien sûr c'est bien
joué
mais ça fait pas très peur quand même
ouais
le score de Dumbledore je pourrais
l'ajouter
en bas là mais bon ça serait moche quand
même
je pourrais ajouter montrer ma dextérité
sur le plan technique
pas très compliqué pour le coup
mais oui effectivement on peut voir le
score où vous voulez
alors comment on peut faire
quand on peut faire ici après tour C3
Maxime qui réfléchit est-ce qu'on double
est-ce qu'on met la tour ensuite j'aime
pas trop c'est quand même dans le
clouage
ça ne va pas trop
ce qu'on peut changer
pas trop qui est ici sauf au final
je trouvais ça tellement naturel mais
bon on va voir quel est son idée
ce qu'il a pas pu rater ça
c'est 5 pour foudre mais c'est très
je trouve ça très artificiel
mais effectivement
tu vois ça se regarde peut-être qu'il
est quand même dame 7
à moi non non pour tous les cas je
prends puis on prend et maintenant je
joue un coup de dames je me découle et
j'attaque et je vais encaisser spion ça
ne va pas
donc tous ces trois petites réflexions
de la part de Maxime et oui il faut
choisir un coup
avec Maxime ce qui est bien thorac C8
tour des C1 et Cavalo 7 il protège comme
ça
et voilà bon ouais pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas il protège sa tour il se déclene
c'est une bonne solution aussi alors
évidemment on avait un beau cavalier en
E5 on l'a reculé mais bon c'est pas très
très grave on va échanger des tours
tranquillement on a toujours la paire de
fou qui est compenser les noirs sont pas
mieux parce que il y a quand même un
pion isolé ici en dessin mais voilà
c'est une position assez équilibrée oui
il se passe pas énormément de choses
pour être honnête
mais on est content une petite nul
solide ça nous va en fait hein
Maxime aura les blancs dans la dernière
d'aujourd'hui en tout cas on rappelle
ton 1 de 9 rondes Maxime va chez agrafe
3 sur 4
et donc
voilà on est quand même
on est quand même
on est bien dans cet endroit donc on n'a
pas besoin de de prendre des risques
inconsidérés
je vais essayer d'ajouter du texte
regardez-moi ça
regardez je vous ajoute ça et après je
vais le caler quelque part trois sur
quatre
comme ça les gens ah non j'ai oublié le
ça on arrêtera de demander
moi ça
fait un truc un petit peu
on le met où on le met là
voilà
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai mis un espace
entre le
et on a
j'espère que la que Vanessa qui m'a aidé
à mettre ce choix en place vers à jamais
ça parce que
c'est moche mais bon
c'est public qui décide
alors qu'avec cette qu'est-ce qui a été
joué par Google
9 minutes contre 14
et on est bien Maxime pas du tout
inquiet pas loin du monde
on prend ouais tout à fait
une attaque non
pour ça mais ouais elle va pas le dire
mais elle va regarder ça elle va dire
ouh là quand même
il joue G4 ok donc c'est pas une attaque
hein c'est quelque chose de positionnel
on veut faire j'ai cinq c'est pas mal
j'aime bien G4 ça crée vraiment une meuf
positionnelle autour du roi noir est-ce
qu'on ferait pas H6 là le premier
réflexe c'est de jouer H6 pour empêcher
les histoires à base de G5 et voilà de
voir
de voir ce qui se passe
parce que j'ai 5 a l'air d'être une
menace c'est pas mal son coup j'ai 4 H 6
soit tempo quasiment
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
est-ce qu'il va faire un coup comme ça
j'ai trois rois G2 amélioré et peut-être
éventuellement plus tard passer une tour
par là et c'est attaquer
on n'y croit pas à l'attaque
c'est pas ce qu'il va faire ici
on voit qu'il a du mal quand même à
créer du jeu 5 minutes d'avance ouais il
y a quand même c'est un signe il a du
mal à créer du jeu Google et pourtant il
a envie parce qu'il a envie de revenir
dans ce temps-là il a envie de gagner
évidemment
et quand même pas pas très bien et je
joue j'ai trois
est-ce qu'on commence à liquider ou pas
c'est aussi ça la question
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a une
urgence folle à liquider surtout qu'on
laisse on laisse des choses comme plus
on prend ces trois
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça c'est la
grande question
est-ce qu'on va on va chatouiller par là
on chatouille celui-ci mais bon
franchement
même vous baisser
tout à fait raisonnable et voilà protège
le pion et effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on
a accompli avec ces derniers
peut-être clarifier une fois pour toute
clarifier en C3
j'ai trois je crois que c'est plutôt un
coup d'amélioration on va jouer deux il
lui demande qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
et peut-être éventuellement si par
exemple tu reprends puis on prend
peut-être éventuellement ranger deux
tours
d'amélioration je dirais
il joue foutais ça qui avait été
proposé dans le chat pour jouer 4 il
veut forcer les événements en train de
Maxime
[Musique]
rikiki kids ouais mais il y a le ah
ouais c'est vrai après tout prend ces
trois je suppose ici de faire ça et ça
c'est vrai que c'était pas mal
c'était un plan mais faut C5 a l'air
assez raisonnable on menace foubecca
dame dire jouer rapidement par gokesh on
s'enlève
du clouage et maintenant on peut faire
fou B4 forçant les événements
mais si on a encore envie de remarquer
comment on fait
comment on fait ici peut-être tours 2
certes mais bon pour ces deux on va
finir par prendre à me prendre il y a
toujours ton C8 donc on va faire tout
reprendre et puis tour c'est vite
et bonne chance pour pouvoir que ce soit
ici avec les Blancs
ouais une question ici jouable aussi
clairement enfin d'abord il faut
protéger le
fouet d'amener 7 c'est vrai que ça ça
pose des questions quand même
intéressant
pose une petite question c'est pas si on
veut le prendre mais
ça reste quand même c'est dans l'air
on va voir maxime a joué fubé 4 kb5 est
venu un tempo waouh
il veut venir c'est 7 et oui sur dame de
7 tu veux faire ton C7 maintenant malin
comme tout
OK et sur dame aussi s'il veut faire
cavalier des quatre l'autre lait de
cavalier on gagne un tempo on protège ce
pion et la dame va être obligé de
reculer
donc comment on fait ici avec les avec
les noirs
toujours
est-ce que je peux faire tourner cette
quand même c'est ça la question je me
lasse rien mais elle est belle cette
tour en C7
peut-être ça vous me direz
pour forcer un échange
on est bien obligé d'échanger mais on a
tout reprend
donc on reprend et tout va bien pour les
Noirs une fois de plus
on aime ce que fait Maxime qui joue
solide
qui est pas inquiet pour dessous on voit
ton C8 jouer
ça va les guider
et c'est toujours c'est toujours très
très égal quand je vous le disais depuis
le début cette paire de fou qu'on pense
le pion des isolé
il prend il reprend
plus d'attaque sur la colonne h
même si ça existait pas trop
ouais on sent il joue mieux à chaque je
trouve qu'il joue aujourd'hui que hier
mais c'est normal c'est normal c'est
tournant
tournant honnêtement cette partie
conduit dite sigle
la le tournoi bah clairement cette
partie de vie dite aura été le tournant
du match alors effectivement c'est pas
fait on en est ami parcours qui est FD4
Maxime pas du tout impressionné et oui
qui est en train de lui dire écoute mon
jeune ami Google
j'ai défendu des poubelles contre
Carlsen
j'ai une position normale
je vois pas comment tu vas me faire mal
il a pas tort
ok qui est pas
vraiment pas impressionnant
ouais en plus on échange des cavaliers
dans tout va bien tout va bien
plus il y a des changes plus ça va faire
regardez ça va être ça va être un truc
comme ça qui va se passer Dame des trois
dame 5 un moment il va il va échanger là
et ça va faire nul
l'école française de la souffrance et
oui mvl qui
[Musique]
parfois c'était limite on a l'impression
qu'il pourrait du plaisir à défendre ces
trucs
à prouver que de toute façon c'était nul
et donc ouais une position comme ça ça
le fait sourire
c'est juste
c'est une blague
après la partie quand ça va être noir à
jabot va être intéressant ouais donc
dans la prochaine tu es en train de nous
dire qu'il aura les blancs contre un
jabov
OK
et bien ouais mais rajabo joue moins en
ce moment tu es quand même plus
dangereux il y a quelques années
ça reste un jeu incroyable ah non t'es
pas en train de nous dire ça contre qui
joue tu te projettes
te projette pas trop
on va regarder je vais vous dire ça tout
de suite quand il joue Maxime à la
suivante
dernière partie de la journée
il aura il aura les blancs contre Abdou
satorov ça sera beau à voir Raja bof
étant à la dernière ronde
il aura les blancs contre donc le
champion du monde rapide 2021 toujours
très actif ou 3 jouer
mais la petite pression
sur ce pion des mais c'est vraiment rien
de quoi être inquiet je peux prendre
je peux prendre et jouer quelque chose
comme dame quelque part d'ams5 par
exemple
non pas ça
j'étais pas content beaucoup de MC5 mais
bon après on n'est jamais obligé de
prendre pourquoi prendre
cavalier prend on va arriver en a pas
envie de faire apprendre on se crée une
faiblesse cavalier prend joint tempo par
Google qui va jouer Maxime est-ce qu'il
va jouer le coup nature
bon même si le fou peut pas trop revenir
après
il y a d'autres coûts qui ont l'air très
bien aussi
je sais pas dame C6 par exemple
faut juste protéger le pion ne pas
gâcher le pion il va le voir Maxime
c'est dans ses compétences
c'est lui ça peut-être dame c'est 6 plus
précis ouais on est d'accord
oui aussi attaquer des cinq et empêcher
des coups comme fouet 8 parce que
attention elle a peur de fou avec des
pions sur les deux ailes ça peut mal
tourner parfois pour les blancs
ouais il envoie l'ombre effectivement
alors peut-être aussi il s'adapte au
style de son adversaire
ils sont assez universel ces jeunes
joueurs chinois indiens c'était à 15 ans
les jeunes joueurs chinois maintenant
c'est fini c'est les Indiens
tout le monde joue tout le monde c'est
très simple c'est
il y a 10 joueurs et tout le monde joue
contre tout le monde
et dans le Blitz qui aura lieu à partir
de vendredi et samedi c'est un tournoi
où tout le monde joue tout le monde mais
avec chaque couleur donc 18 rondes
il y a des joueurs non il y a pas de
place pour les candidats mais ça compte
quand même dans la course dans cette
idée circuit de circuit de la fidélité
qui est
et bien on marque des points et ceux qui
a marqué le plus de points à la fin de
l'année et je crois que c'est Google qui
en tête en ce moment devant Guiri donc
c'est important pour goûter
mais c'est important pour la confiance
de Maxime c'est une évidence et je vous
donne ces 6 Maxime il est précis Maxime
machinagrave il fait plaisir quand il
est comme ça il prend deux trois minutes
dans une position quand même assez plate
et il joue et joue ça
le price je sais pas on pourra aller
voir la question a été posée
régulièrement j'irai voir la prochaine
pause le prices pool
exact mais il peut y avoir aussi des des
starting fille comme on dit des des
cachets de départ
mais vous inquiétez pas trop pour eux
c'est voilà c'est il gagne des bons prix
personne
[Musique]
personne va repartir trop malheureux
je crois que le 8e de finale de
mvl en speech et quand même après le
tournoi
j'ai vu ça j'ai vu les dates je sais
plus exactement quand c'est mais en tout
cas
clairement c'est pas pendant le tournoi
sinon ça serait trop dur effectivement
salut à tous c'est plaisir
alors
faites ça quand votre adversaire a
simplement de casse blanche mettez vos
pions sur noir seront jamais perdu
et là honnêtement on voit pas
on voit pas ce que peuvent faire les
blancs on voit pas ce que peuvent faire
les noirs
ça pue la nul
non 8 septembre non c'est pas ça c'est
pas ça c'était
[Musique]
ouais top 3 du filet circuit merci stunt
top 3 du fil des circuit
actuellement c'est karwana qui est déjà
qualifié à travers
à travers la Coupe du monde donc lui
saute
Google donc comme quoi je raconte pas
n'importe quoi pas tout le temps en tout
cas parfois je suis une info
donc voilà donc pour Google c'est
important même si les rapides comptent
moins même si peut-être à moyenne l'eau
ça compte c'est pas extraordinaire non
plus ça compte quand même
donc intéressant de suivre ça je crois
que Maxime est trop détaché pour pour
avoir une chance
aux filles des circuits
et il joue fou hein Maxime qui est une
proposition nulle en gros hein il dit
vas-y joue ouais fin je joue béca 4
toujours âgé 2 et puis c'est bon on a
marre
on en a marre ouais mais ça c'est
logique
donc on nous a dit dans le chat 41 500
dollars à se partager
il y a deux tournois à mon avis ils ont
des ils ont des starting filles pour
tout à fait honnête c'est pas du tout
les prix 41 500 ça fait 4000 de moyenne
par jour pour jouer 5 jours c'est pas du
tout leur tarif
donc il y a des il y a des starting fils
à peu près sûr
dame d'un foubeca de jouer et Dame des
trois et ça va être une répétition on va
aller sur notre partie très certainement
une fois que la répétition est signée
à moins que Google la joue à 4 30 contre
2900 contre 2919 ça y est je crois 9 19
je vois pas trop l'intérêt
ouais il va pas il va pas chercher la
petite bête je crois que
possible pour qualifier il en reste plus
qu'une c'est les deux places du Grand
Suisse qui aura lieu fin octobre à l'île
de Man
et donc voilà ça sera
ça sera à ce moment-là ou jamais un
escalier résa
quand même des chances où l'eau
donc voilà allez à deux chances
bon on va voir on espère évidemment un
double français pour ce grand chiffre
mais ça sera très très fort
le grand sud est le plus compliqué
NEP qu'à le grand sud c'est plus
compliqué
à la Coupe du Monde c'est pas vraiment
simple il y a aucun système qui est
simple honnêtement
je sais pas moi je joue pas moi je joue
pas
allez deux semaines à l'île de Vannes
pour faire 11000 merci non je fais pas
je ferais pas l'île de Man en plus il
pleut sous la pluie encore au soleil 11
nul voilà on est bien quand même mais
sous la pluie non voilà donc il y a deux
places à l'île de Man est-ce que allez
résa joue oui rikikit il est inscrit il
y a une liste qui est disponible sur le
site de la fille
c'est quoi un Suisse un Suisse un
tournoi un système suisse
voilà
donc il y aura il y aura au moins 5
français
je crois que au moins et au plus il y
aura 5 français qu'est-ce qui joue books
a et Marc-André à mort Audi qui a une
reçu une white card
voilà parce que normalement c'est les
100 meilleurs joueurs du monde au hello
qui sont invités alors après ils
descendent en fonction du Hello
en fonction des refus il descendent au
vélo mais c'est vrai qu'il donne des
walk hard aux jeunes voilà donc c'est
bien et puis c'est quand même très
formateur donc le système suisse c'est
un appareil manque par exemple s'il y
avait un joueur ça me suce est très
simple il y avait un joueur le 1 joue
contre le 11 le jeu 2 joue contre le 12
le 3 joue contre le 13 on coupe à la
moitié et on fait les appareillerment
comme ça c'est le nom d'un système
d'appariement en fait
donc c'est avantage j'aimerais l'eau ça
c'est vrai
c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un qui a un plus
gros et l'eau va jouer normalement une
moyenne et l'eau plus faible que par
exemple maritime
il sera jamais fort dans les appareils
donc il va jouer toujours des
adversaires plus forts
donc c'est un système qui permet de
rendre pas complètement random
aléatoire les appareils
et même c'est officiel je suis content
je trouve que franchement vu la
situation au temps de 46 contre 8 20
je pense que c'est Maxime qui a le plus
de chance de faire quelque chose dans
cette partie
à la fidélité ah c'est pas c'est pas la
fidélité qui a confirmé qu'avez off
aller au candidat si manuscrit on s'est
largement
c'est à dire que s'il y a un des joueurs
qui refuse c'est marqué que c'est le
quatrième qui va s'il y a deux joueurs
qui refusent c'est pris où est l'eau
donc Amazon
joue pas c'est lui qui joue
il a eu son deuxième tour deuxième tour
très compliqué pour la base de fin
deuxième tour très chaud et après cela a
donné une force qui lui a poussé
jusqu'au demi-finale
ah ouais non mais il peut la perdre
Google avec de 45 il est en petite forme
maintenant ce tournoi honnêtement
je vois pas d'un mauvais œil que voilà
un fou c'est vite arrivé
ouais c'est ça il était un frère
exactement à bazov il s'est dit
incroyable j'ai gagné ce tour je peux
gagner je vais gagner
donc maintenant est-ce qu'il revient
protégé ou pas
c'est 5 ou 6
ah c'est jeunes Indiens
mais c'est bien
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là est-ce qu'on se
ferait pas la vue
full screen
ah non
on veut
on va changer le
de 55
pour Google
et notre français qui a 650 qui contrôle
très très bien la pendule et qui vient
de jouer non il réfléchit sur roi G2
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire Maxime du
coup c'est plus aligné du tout
Maxime qui a comme depuis le début 4
minutes 4 minutes d'avance
je suis sur gooche je suis sur vide là
je vais me mettre là
première rang on est là on regarde
on regarde Maxime que va-t-il faire
est-ce qu'il envisage des coups comme
fou ensuite dame c'est de ça se calcule
mais bon ça allait un peu juste après il
faut prendre des cinq
on est aussi moche
et ouais
j'en ai bien
j'ai amené mon siège spécial
et on regarde
le spectacle on adore le spectacle
je regarde et je vous parle en plus il
faut faire un peu de silence quand même
oui ça serait bon peut-être pour demain
tiens je mets des pop-corn
où je me prends les pop-corn en fait je
bouffe des pop-corn
alors Maxime qui réfléchit j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup vraiment il
prend son temps quand il a besoin
il voit que Google
[Musique]
évidemment
franchement
c'est vrai qu'il parle derrière
attention attention là-bas attention
arrêtez arrêtez
il parle le jeune on les voit parler le
monsieur est sans son fils
qu'est-ce qui va nous faire Maxime il
est en train de calculer là c'est sûr
non je crois pas
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
de
mvl il faut que je le
je vais ajouter
parce que sinon on va me
fatiguer
mvla 3 sur 4 qui est en tête du tournoi
3 sur 4
il est là il est à Maxime il réfléchit
beaucoup allez Maxime
allez merci un petit coup d'accélérateur
allez un petit coup sur ses 5 ouais mais
je voyais pas le truc je comprenais pas
le délire après Dame des trois parce que
vous prend des 5 menaces et je vois pas
comment protège le pion des peut-être
dame B2 mais alors attention
pour faire sur vous prend des cinq fous
prends le 3 tactique Fraisse
oh là là ça marche la jauge de Mouv' pas
non il y a une autre chose dame c'est 5
pieds à jouer mon grand
lame c'est 5 joué par mvl ça c'est ça
c'est du solide ça c'est mon garçon
ouais mais d'accord mais c'est des trucs
quand même très
si tu rates un truc dans ce genre de
d'acrobatie comme comme fou c'est 5 et
bien tu es quand même tu es pas bien
et maintenant comment on fait
comment on fait on n'aime pas ça nous on
veut du solide
chacun quasiment
fous ces trois menaces gains
comment on fait pour le protéger on sait
pas
compliqué j'aime bien fou ces trois
allez
est-ce que
un Maxime peut en cacher un autre et non
le coup proposé et landame 7 dame 7
c'est bien ça la mec ça c'est du solide
ça ça c'est du solide dame 5 menace une
petite une petite échange là sympathique
comment il fait gouker cette pas
possible il y a fouder 6 comment il fait
gokuche
on est bien ouh là là il a mis un coup
de
il a pas rigolé là Maxime
oh là il s'est concentré il a trouvé un
truc barre d'acier on adore
ouais mesdames C7 Adam c'est intéressant
ok effectivement et non madame je prends
je prends et je joue des 4 et attention
c'est les cas dont je vous parlais ou la
paire de fou pour se révéler très très
forte
alors dame 7 qu'est-ce qui va être joué
par Google une cinquante vas-y Google je
réfléchis réfléchis et joue à fond la
gagne surtout laisse toi laisse toi 5
secondes et après tu joues à fond la
gagne ouais tu fais ça
tu fais ça on va être bien
on va être bien Nath
allez non mais là je crois qu'il va
revenir à ces à la réalité
j'ai l'impression qu'il veut absolument
gagner mais il a pas du tout la position
pour prendre des risques il a joué quoi
je vais d'amener 4 min
3 il a joué à fond j'adore c'est lui
Dame des trois donc il tourne en rond
pour essayer de gagner
ok qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici avec les
noirs et il joue fou et un Maxime machin
grave dame D1 est-ce que ça serait pas
en train de répéter
est-ce qu'il va demander trois fois mais
non tu es pas moins bien Maxime
vas-y vas-y je fous B4 il va s'envoyer
en l'air t'inquiète
il va s'envoyer en l'air
il a regardé le petit regard de Maxime
et non ça a fabriqué des quatre fous
c'est 3 mètres jouets c'est jouer
par Maxime agrave il y a bien eu trois
répètes mais il a raison vas-y laisse-le
s'envoyer en l'air tu as raison
surtout ne pas réclamer
c'est bien en plus il peut se tromper ça
casse un peu le rythme ça peut rajouter
une minute il est pas du tout moins bien
qu'avait les deux pour faire cavalier F4
ok ok c'est pas grave et si on mettait
le faux au centre hein c'est pas quoi si
on met le faux sang c'est jouer
c'est jouer faux 5
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire Dame des trois
OK
quelle idée il y a un pas
il a joué à fond
mais bon on est bien il joue j'ai 5 et
pour faire fouger 6
plus tard pour l'instant il y a le pion
mais empêche cavalier F4 attention
Google
qui jouait avec le feu on n'est pas dans
un Opin en Espagne mon cherokeh
c'est Maxime Vacher grave en face
allez parce qu'il a il a percé comme ça
un oiseau en Espagne et vas-y que je te
fais 9 sur 9 ou 8 et demi sur 9 je te
joue à gagne dans n'importe quelle
position alors ça les avantages mais on
peut quand même être puni par ce genre
de joueur c'est quand même
c'est quand même un autre niveau
évidemment qu'est-ce qu'il a fait fou
aussi j'ai pas été update sur mon écran
comment ça se fait ça oula je vais
essayer de remettre à jour et un
problème il a joué aussi ça il y a pas
le coup
il y a pas le coup
il y a pas le coup faut aussi se jouer
un peu comme
elle est du côté
quand j'appuie sur Entrée ça a du côté
ah non ah non
allez Maxime on va essayer de la de la
mettre parce qu'il y a les après il y a
les et les monomaniaques qui vont me
dire c'est pas en face
c'est quasi en face
c'est pas aligné alors faut aussi Dame
des trois fois
j'ai pas les coups moi
j'ai un pourquoi j'ai pas les couilles
un bug
il y a un bug
on voit mais c'est la position Dame des
trois c'est quoi la position 31 il a
joué quoi
et là je fous aussi
non c'est la position c'est comme ça moi
j'ai un jouet
ça y est bien joué bien joué Maxime
très très bien joué
55 secondes pour goûter
est-ce que je peux tout réiquer bien sûr
que je peux tout échiquier évidemment
que je peux tourner
ah ça m'a fait bugger les pendules
on l'enfer
je te remercie pas
mais bon c'est pas grave on va faire ça
ah non
ça m'a fait bugger les pendules
incroyables de ton échec et
alors rouage 2
qu'est-ce qui se passait sur si on
prenait le pion il y avait tout
simplement ça
ramasser le cahier donc roi H2 menace de
prendre le pion maintenant
il veut rager de ça crée Google
il a joué à fond de 18 contre 0,36
secondes
légère avantages au temps
ouais mais je suis pas sûr que ça soit
franchement c'est pas le bon client au
maximum pour faire les trucs comme ça à
mon avis
je tenterai pas moi
je sais que mes parents d'échiquier Miss
clic je sais
mais effectivement oui mais
enfin
passons ne parlons pas trop technique ça
on va perdre tout le monde
alors faut quand même jouer un coup
Maxime notre Maxime national là
qui est quand même
impérial depuis le début et vous aussi
et vas-y et en chatouille en chatouille
attention attention ok je perds de fou
quand même pour les noirs
paires de fou ça peut mal tourner ce
genre d'histoire
pourquoi la pendule tourne du côté de
Maxime là il a joué Maxime
oh là là
c'est pas du tout là il y a un problème
il y a un problème de retransmission au
niveau du temps le temps tourne pour
Maxime mais en fait il a joué fou prend
des cinq jouets par gooche je vous
montre la position tant pis on n'a pas
répondu on a léger souci de
retransmission sur le cheeseccom mais
c'est pas grave
je vais vous faire suivre comme ça
et la dameuse par Maxime personne n'a vu
venir
enfin pas moi en tout cas et surtout
prends il y a perpétuel au minimum et au
maximum aussi ou pas
et roi G2 jouer
non faut prendre
les cinq dames deux il est obligé de
prendre le perpète
nul c'est perpète c'est perpète pourquoi
je vous le montre dame des 7 si on venge
ici s'il y a de F5 la md7 on peut jamais
courir avec le fou si on va là je suis
et c'est nul on va essayer de voir une
autre partie si c'est pas terminé vite
contre
Eric easy ça a donné nul apparemment
donc
ensuite on a ça qui est terminé et on a
pas lambda contre Harry Krishna on va
essayer d'aller voir je vais essayer de
récupérer cette partie au plus vite
alors
partie c'est la dernière partie qui
reste et on a Prague
Prague avec les Blancs on va tourner
chez qui
est blanc contre un Krishna qui mieux
pourquoi les noirs sont complètement
gagnants
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour Maxime ça
vous prend F2 jolie si tu reprends il y
a B2 et on finit
es B2 jouer
avec les pièces là ce qui met les pièces
entre
il fait dames voyez il s'est passé ça
B2K
mais il y a échec
qu'est-ce qu'il fait sur échec notre ami
ah non c'est au ce plan
je me change dans le public je m'assois
là
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il a joué il y a
un problème parce qu'il a mal à doublé
sa pièce notre ami Prague tour reprend
ou là comment il a joué comment il a
fait ça
comment il a réussi
je pense ok il va attendre
il dit à Harry ok vas-y j'ai 6 ça c'est
bien joué J6 puis on prend
on prend en jouet
voilà ça y est on a ah non moi aussi
oh
joli je pensais
mais moi si superbe pourquoi super
menace maths Tour Eiffel un seul coup
pour empêcher F5 échec quand même tout
reprend F5 tomber 4 échecs le roi
revient sur la troisième on encaisse la
tour on arrête le pion on a une tour de
plus et on a gagné
et on va voir tout de suite les
résultats
les résultats
alors qu'est-ce que ça donne au niveau
des résultats de la ronde et Maxime ma
chère qui le seul à faire nul à Johnny
Cash qui bat vite ah je vais mal vu
alors maxime est grave qui fait nul
contre
la question on l'a vu et hâte de cette
Europe qui a battu gamer
bon il se passe énormément de choses
évidemment on est on est focus sur
Maxime ça c'est une évidence et rajabov
qui vient de gagner quatre parties
consécutives apparemment
c'est vrai qu'il a perdu la première
ronde 4 sur 5 pour adjabov 3 et demi sur
5 pour Maxime Vacher la grave tout reste
à faire mais il y a un petit écart qui
s'est creusé
on a quatre joueurs à 2 et demi et
4 joueurs à deux et demi qui meurt à
deux visita 2
erghezya 2
on va regarder d'abord les appariements
on va peut-être regarder la partie de
Raja bof on va regarder la partie
de la ronde 6 et on va surveiller à
jabbov du coup maintenant on va lui
souhaiter du malheur à Raja bof oui
alors merci ma chère grave allez blanc
contre Abdou ça torov belle partie
encore une fois avec les snack gamer
gretchup Prague
visite Raja BOV à visite on est pour
visite et Google
je pense que la prochaine est dans dans
une petite vingtaine de minutes on va
regarder pour l'instant
si on se regardait la partie ou
peut-être avant je sais pas faut rester
pour savoir je franchement je crois que
les horaires c'est tous les tous les
heures et demie mais quand ça se termine
aussitôt j'en sais rien
on va aller voir la partie de Raja bof
elle est belle la partie drajabov
qu'est-ce qui nous a fait un Jobo alors
on va aller voir ça tout de suite
et envoie une slave ok il faut 5 qui est
tout à fait normal ou là fouder 3 c'est
en Molly hein faut des trois c'est pas
du tout censé être dangereux qui avait
les H4 et le bon coup ici enfin le coup
le plus dangereux il faut des trois est
pas mauvais
et ok on se développe gentiment
pas du tout d'obtenir un avantage
d'ouverture
mais il est pas bien même
bon parti où se passe pas grand chose
pour l'instant très très solide
attention on aime bien les noirs
ce qui était franchement pas bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi tu as
oublié est une gaffe
et la mâche juste on va faire ça waouh
c'est complètement massacré un jabof vu
que son roi
Master Class de greach mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
tour à 8 OK
je sais pas
3 qui est c'est encore de faire nul
et là il est complètement gagnant mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans cette
partie c'est pas possible
il fait tout parfaitement apparemment
oh le coup on le coup de great show ici
on le coup de critchouc alors là alors
là
j'aurais dû directement mais dites-moi
d'aller à la fin de la partie
directement
pour le coup de gris de chouk ici quelle
horreur
quelle horreur
et voyez mais ça nous fait un champion
cambridgehuk un grand joueur
voilà il a joué cavalier F2 ici
et puis on prend l'homme
alors qu'il y avait chose complètement
en main il suffit de continuer l'attaque
je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'elle monte là
je sais quoi le meilleur ici damage 5
ici mais même ça ça doit
ça c'est complètement gagnant aussi avec
des damages 7 qui peuvent arriver des E4
qui peuvent arriver on n'a pas de contre
jeu parce que si on fait tourner en V7
il y a toujours tout reprend un 4 et
c'est un désastre oh là là
et ouais donc ça nous fait relativiser
un sur nos gafs voilà pensez à quelque
chose
quand vous faites ce genre de ça fait
une gaffe et tout regardez
masterclass de A à Y et Z qui se passe
mal
donc ouais my cavalier F2
cavalier F2 c'est dommage c'était bien
vu
puis on prend dame terrible
sur ce la dernière ronde a lieu ah
normalement 14h30 peut-être un peu avant
donc n'hésitez pas à revenir un peu
avant
mais
on reste avec Maxime je vais encore
montrer une fois de plus le classement
il est pas loin de la tête un énorme
coup de bol une dame contre greachu donc
voilà tout reste possible pour Maxime
qui jouera contre le champion du monde
de partir rapidement
gros match en perspective merci de me
suivre je reviens très bientôt pour
cette dernière ronde de la deuxième
journée du tata style
rapide demain sera la dernière journée
comme d'habitude à 11h30 mais d'abord on
a une dernière partie qui va être
passionnante avec les Blancs Maxime qui
va essayer d'en faire quelque chose
c'est certain il joue très bien
aujourd'hui donc on espère le meilleur
pour ces dernières parties
à tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analysez avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs émoticônes
et les emojis disparaîtront au bout de
quelques secondes en revanche les
notations de coûts les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
et je suis de retour
pour la dernière partie de la journée
mais certainement pas la dernière partie
du tournoi
on va voir Maxime Vacher la grave qui va
jouer
cette dernière partie
face à
Toro
le jeune joueur ouzbek un champion
olympique a déjà beau palmarès un
champion du monde de partir rapide
bon bref vraiment un très très bon
joueur effectivement ouais c'est le
problème de c'est tournoi en dirant en 9
rondes pardon c'est qu'il y a voilà
quelques joueurs qui vont avoir plus de
fois les noirs que les Blancs qu'est-ce
que je vous dise c'est comme ça
après c'est un critère de départage
est-ce que c'est un critère de départage
est-ce qu'on aura des Blitz je vais
m'enseigner pour demain tiens
on peut regarder le format je vais
enlever le format
est-ce qu'il y a des Blitz ou pas
[Musique]
ouais non il y a pas de j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a pas de
il y a pas de départage
en tout cas c'est pas annoncé
donc
pas le départage annoncé
écoutez a priori il y a pas de départage
donc c'est un peu pas de chance pour
pour Maxime si il venait
c'était amené à être execo premier execo
et bien il aurait eu plus de fois les
Noirs c'est comme ça
tirage au sort
ouais je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
Berti axe c'est un peu bizarre
quel projet chez qui
j'ai pas
bah j'espère je vais faire j'aime bien
faire des commentaires je veux jouer un
petit peu
un peu de Bundes
un peu de Bundes un peu de partie par
équipe peut-être certainement
non
j'y crois pas
je n'y crois pas je n'y crois plus
j'ai plus à fois
c'est gentil Carib j'aime bien te voir
jouer
ouais ça fait au moins une personne
moi j'aime pas j'aime pas trop ça
si j'aime bien ça mais bon mes résultats
sont plus tout à fait
en accord avec mes espérances voilà
donc je vais jouer un petit peu mais
peut-être moins que cet été
assez dur de revenir à 200700 je vous le
garantis Étienne alors Étienne il y a le
talent c'est sûr mais c'est pas évident
les années passent c'est un beau
challenge
on verra on verra s'il y arrive s'il
arrive c'est vraiment un bel exploit
de revenir à 2007
ça serait vraiment
impressionnant
alors est-ce qu'on a non pas de date sur
le départage tout va bien
ouais pour macro c'est pas du tout
pour moi il est pas favori après c'est
un bol challenge
alors on va essayer de trouver la caméra
de Maxime
pour voir tout ça est-ce que ça serait
celle-là non c'est pas celle-là
est-ce que c'est celle-là
on sait pas
où
est-ce que c'est celle-là on sait pas
non plus
et est-ce que c'est celle-là
on sait pas non plus
non ça c'est
pas bon soit la 4
et non c'est la 5 Maxime
une nouvelle table je crois dans ce
tournoi
il est blanc contre Trump
et évidemment il est en forme il va pas
s'arrêter en si bon chemin il va essayer
d'aller les blancs il va essayer de
mettre la pression
à notre jeune ami ouzbek très très bon
joueur très très
sérieux on le voit dans les tournois il
est quand même très
très concentré un peu une attitude qui
fait penser beaucoup à Gary Kasparov
vraiment on sent quelqu'un d'habiter
qui est là pour gagner ton nom récavik
beau tournoi recave conseiller
conseiller par la maison mais je n'irai
pas avec
je joue pas d'Open désolé peut-être que
j'irai j'ai vu qu'il y avait le
championnat d'Europe individuel je vais
peut-être me chauffer pour le
championnat individuel très probablement
mais c'est l'année prochaine donc d'ici
la fin d'année peut-être que j'irai
jouer des rapides et Blitz aussi
champion du monde rapides c'est champion
d'Europe rapide j'ai vu qu'il y avait ça
ça me chauffe aussi faut voir où c'est
c'est pas mal je vais essayer de me
qualifier 18 septembre il y a le
dernier et la dernière calife du
champion de chaise tours donc je vais
essayer de me qualifier aussi on va voir
les championnats d'Europe par équipe oui
mais qui quitte c'est la sélection et
pas
officiel alors j'espère que je vais être
pris
par le sélectionnant en tout cas
effectivement c'est ça je vais plus au
soleil que sous la pluie
donc ouais très probablement champion
d'Europe par équipe
on verra
mais oui
on verra mais oui
ah oui quand même avec des coéquipiers
pareil
E4 jouet par un Maxime La Grave ah bon
une partie alors les stats sicilienne 4
5 6 6e je me rappelle que vous l'avez
fait souffrir mvl
dans ce champion justement il y avait
gagné un match G6
est-ce qu'on a une petite chance de voir
un hasard champion d'Europe par équipe
écoute je laisse
[Musique]
la Fédération elle sélectionneur
communiquer à leur
[Musique]
dire
on verra vous verrez c'est rien
ces trois D5 joué par
Abdou satorov C3 et le coup
qui est censé être embêtant pour cette
ordre de coup c'est trop simplement je
compte le fou vous voyez et on veut
simplement
occuper le centre des 5 si plusieurs
options le coût principal ici c'est E40
voilà
exactement
c'est officiel ou officieux
qu'est-ce qui est
tout est officieux tant que c'est pas
public en fait
ce qu'il veut en fait tant qu'il a pas
publié ça sélectionneur
[Musique]
Rennes est officiel tant que c'est pas
annoncé en fait
E5 fougères ok normalement on joue des 4
ici pour essayer de faire calibrer 5
échecs d'abord ok pourquoi pas
ça se tient à priori cavalier C6 voilà
exactement et petit rock ok alors ce
qu'il fait Maxime
et sur fu G7 il va faire des quatre
ouais le dragon hyper accéléré n'est pas
prisé à haut niveau alors déjà on peut
pas la voir le dragon hyper accéléré
c'est ça le problème
là il y a la russoli mot et sur G6 comme
on l'a vu dans la partie il y a trois
donc déjà pour la voir c'est pas c'est
pas évident
après c'est pas une mauvaise ouverture
c'est ça qui retarde le développement du
Fou G7 et on dirait une sorte de
française avec 6 mais c'est vrai qu'on a
joué G6 donc c'est toujours un peu
embêtant toujours affaiblissant
cavalier H6 très logique pour aller en
F5 et faire pression sur ce pion qui va
certainement arriver en décape
d'où cette Europe qui joue quand même
il y a aussi il a raison Maxime Lagarde
des câbles puis on prend à me prendre
qui donne pas de hyper accéléré
et voilà il y a beaucoup de théories et
F6 E5 etc etc
mais Maxime a décidé de jouer C3
le petit coup sur
donc comment on fait
priori on va quand même sur des 4 il va
faire quel est F5 c'est ça
ok mais attention on peut se découle et
parfois dans ma 4 peut être une idée
ça peut être dangereux ou même si on
prend ça
des 4 ce serait plutôt pion on prend
puis on prend et qui va les F5 mais dans
ma 4 encore une fois
même ah ok BD il y aura qui prend des
cas dix ans d'Ama 4 un TAC ici admettons
ton C8 et maintenant je fais que des
deux je vais faire H3 au prochain coup
ça a l'air quand même très très bien
pour les blancs selon l'histoire
et je vous ai trois Maxime ok ok
pas fan
pas fan de Détroit
alors maintenant l'idée à mon avis c'est
sur cavalier F5 il faut prendre ses 6
mais prend ses 6 dans ma 4
on attaque le fou on attaque le pion
vous prend F3 c'est le désastre
on a perdu une tour
donc c'est ça donc des trois empêche
cavalier F5 par une petite tactique
c'est possible que les blancs que les
noirs doivent prendre un F3 d'abord
des trois fougères 7 et maintenant il
fait fougères évidemment
alors comment on fait ici
il y a c'est pas très clair pour moi
peut-être ouais
quand même
donc là faut faire attention à pas faire
H3 parce que le pion est en prise donc
d'abord faut penser 6b prend ses 6 et H3
ça peut être une bonne version il décide
de faire H3 direct bon là il va prendre
c'est quasi certain
fou des sets aussi un coup
faut prendre un bras on peut jamais
prendre ce pion parce qu'il y a le
cavalier qui traîne
et donc sur petit rock comment on fait
et on va prendre
peut-être un petit coup de fouet 3 pour
chatouiller en C5 ou tout roulant
d'abord
oui exact j'avais oublié le premier H6
tout à fait
H3 ok on a plutôt de ce que je connais
de ces
de ce début on a plutôt envie de
reprendre un cavalier F3 mais bon
et en savoir ce qu'il fait pour que il a
réfléchi un petit peu
alors quel est le coup il réfléchir d'où
ça te refaire en fait pour menacer
6 on est pas mécontent donner la la
paire de fou attention si on fait fou
prends ça donnera toujours des idées
avec eux 6 peut-être des quatre aussi
très solide on joue sur case noire parce
qu'on a échangé notre foodcasse blanche
même aussi c'est un coup ici puis on
prend la jauge j'aime pas trop mais qui
est G5 Tourer
on va on fait pas ça alors
ouais c'est vrai que ça ouvre le jeu ok
j'ai 5 ou 17 ce genre de choses
bon pas forcément extraordinaire ouais
ok j'ai cinq fous d'essai je pensais
qu'on pouvait récupérer mes tours il y
aura de MB6 tout le temps
ouais Maxime qui baille un peu
blitzb prend ses 6 ans et petit rock et
maintenant il fait dame de Maxime ok
protège champion et il va sortir son
cavalier par là pas mal
ouais je comprends ce site intermédiaire
si il prend F3 mais apparemment oui
c'est vrai qu'il a dû avoir peur de
d'empre F3 il s'est dit tour C8
certainement et c'est vrai qu'on va plus
doubler les pions maintenant
c'est ça qui a dû l'embêter et donc il
s'est dit je double les pions et c'est
vrai que c'est pion maintenant sont
quand même des vrais
des vrais cibles
donc intéressant ce qui fait
c'est ce que j'apportais à Magnus
surtout des prépas
après il sait faire un Magnus Carson
vous savez
on va pas prendre comment jouer au final
à manuscrite
de le guider
les ouvertures le travail pénible
travail chronophage
pénible et ça lui permet de garder de
l'énergie de garder des forces pour ces
parties de pas faire ce travail voilà
c'est l'idée d'avoir un second danger en
général
mais il me doit tout ici évidemment
c'est
alors
comment on fait ici avec les noirs pour
jouer à un jeu actif c'est pas évident
j'aime pas du tout les Noirs la
structure est pourrie le foot joue pas
le cavalier au bord
autant vous dire que les blancs sont
vieux ça c'est aucun doute
après à quel point on n'est pas trop
développé mais c'est pas grave parce que
la position est quand même fermée
non Magnus a pas de coach mental il y a
pas besoin de ça
il y a des gens qui ont la chance
[Musique]
d'avoir toutes les qualités
naturellement sur le mental en tout cas
non j'ai pas parlé de ma victoire contre
lui en 10 minutes sur internet non non
c'est juste que parce que la dernière
partie de ce tournoi je pouvais me
qualifier pour la division pour jouer un
match en tout cas pour la division 1 si
je gagnais et donc effectivement
je sais qu'avec Peter ils avaient
discuté il avait décidé de me parce
qu'en fait ceux qui finissent en haut du
classement peuvent choisir les autres
ils peuvent choisir leur match donc il
avait décidé de me choisir
pour prendre sa revanche
cavalier F5
mais j'ai perdu la dernière donc du coup
non on travaille tous ensemble
franchement il y a on doit être
maintenant
les échecs modernes on doit être
flexible et être un peu expert de tout
c'est important on peut plus faire une
seule ouverture comme avant c'est
terminé ce temps-là est révolu
alors cavalier F5
alors après on est plus ou moins expert
sur sur certaines
variantes mais quand même
joué par Maxime
et ne pas donc
on va certainement venir avec le
cavalier ici quoi d'autre j'ai 4 aussi
peu se regarder parce que ce cavalier
est-ce qu'on le met là non parce qu'il y
a fougères donc on est obligé de revenir
quand même qui est pas très agréable
c'est un peu affaiblissant mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il va le faire il
le joue
j'ai quatre cahiers
non on va voir
et maintenant
on va voir
sortir par là ou faire fu F4 pour
menacer dame 3 et encaisser le cavalier
peut-être
c'est être intéressant de voir
F4 ça me démange
mais bon ça se regarde en vrai
ça se regarde parce que F4 F5 et puis
aller
des deux KF3 c'est vrai qu'il y a quand
même il y a quand même beaucoup
d'options très plaisant pour les blancs
ça c'est plutôt bien je suppose qu'il
veut faire F5 ou F6
comme ça attention prend sur G5
ok attention ça peut se retourner contre
les Blancs on a poussé nos pions devant
le roi pas forcément et c'est vrai
qu'après F4 F5
le fou peut être en muré mais bon
toujours pareil
on va faire ça ça peut être H6
je sais pas je suis pas super fan en
fait
faut trois D4 ouais faut 3 D4
certainement effectivement donc c'est
plutôt faux F4 ou KD2
menaces aussi peut-être qu'il y avait
trois pour attaquer le pur ça peut être
pas mal aussi
clairement une option F4 on est d'accord
on est d'accord on est complètement
d'accord parce que par exemple ça ça
c'est chaud attention de pas se
retrouver avec un fonds
serait typiquement en Muret
pour ne plus jamais sortir
ça serait un problème
et Maxime qui a joué kayd2 ouais bon
c'est le coup de la raison quelle idée
c'est pas mal quand même
parce qu'il y en a une belle position et
balade Maxime en pleine confiance
écoute développement il est très bien
déjà il est très bien le Maxou
et ça serait beau de terminer cette
belle journée par une victoire
ça annoncerait quand même une dernière
journée très favorable
des positions complets je crois qu'il va
falloir faire un coup de F6 ou F5 je
sais pas franchement
c'est compliqué de voir ce qu'il faut
faire exactement
il va falloir faire un coup comme ça on
peut pas faire le cavalier doit partir
de H6
ne peut pas aller là on va pas faire
washville et G8 ça serait quand même ça
serait moche ça serait triste
ouais Catherine sur 6 ça serait vraiment
très beau et ouais conduit vite c'est le
tournant très important la partie camp
de visite
plus un vin dit la jauge ouais c'est pas
étonnant voilà après ça reste la jauge
on le voit vous voyez à gauche de votre
écran
alors F6 si nous dit puis on prend puis
on prend à me 6 notre ami mais j'aime
pas ça aller prendre les carotter un
pion là
maintenant le cavalier va venir par là
il va y avoir du contre-jour on n'aime
pas ça
non on laisse les Noirs sortir trop
facilement on n'a pas envie de prendre
un pion comme ça
mais encore une fois ouais non non ça
serait pas bon truc comme ça
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait sur F6 peut-être
aussi ça
fais comment faire
et sur F5
peut-être aussi
peut-être si c'est un peu tôt aussi non
c'est pas bon
c'est pas du tout la même là le pion G4
il y a des choses comme ça peut-être
Dame des 6 tours F4 ce genre de choses
Dame des 6 par exemple
menace d'un mec 4 faut 5 peut-être ça
c'est trois faiblesses
donc F5 c'est complexe
probablement le coup F5
qui est
maintenant que les trois peut-être
toujours compliqué de défendre ce pion
c'est pas tellement le pion c'est aussi
la case aussi
avec une belle fourchette
ça paraît très cher qu'est-ce qu'il a
joué et afficher il réfléchit mais oui
sa position est pas facile
bonne chance Abdou
la jauge est réel
un jour j'ai complètement réel ah bah
oui il a une poubelle hein il a fait son
coup de cavalier F5 G4 et H6 en fait
c'était pas une bonne affaire
sur le
sur le papier on se dit le roi blanc et
affaibli tout ça mais en vrai
en vrai on a perdu du temps et de
l'espace
c'est pas bon
c'est pas bon tout ça
ouais
ouais on peut avoir une belle finale
demain rendre neuf on aura déjà bof mvl
donc ça peut être la finale du tournoi
et donc
on est pas là
ne mettons pas la charrue avant les
bœufs Maxime qui se promène qui prend
ses 4 minutes ça y est on a le matelas
habituel d'avance 4 minutes d'avance on
est bien
Maxime qui joue vite et bien aujourd'hui
il manque un bervu dans les tribunaux
pour l'instant mais je vais aller
m'installer bientôt
non il y a deux tournois en fait un tour
ado rapide un tournoi de Blitz donc
c'est pas mis en commun du tout
c'est deux tournois distincts nous
aurons 2 vainqueurs ou peut-être seul
mais en tout cas il a gagné les deux
tournois
comment il fait la
je vois pas franchement
je trouve ça déprimant comme position
je sais pas du tout ce qui va jouer F5
qui est B3 a l'air pas mal quand même
KFC je vais commencer je vais avoir des
trucs comme ça
attention
mais vous savez quoi je suis très
curieux de voir son prochain coup
ça va pas être beau à mon avis
pas de folichon parce que
simplement il y a un paquet de pièces là
et on sait pas comment s'en dépatouiller
ouais
Maxime qui compte gagner le tournoi de
marche également et joue surtout les
tableaux et c'est vrai que là il se
balade
est-ce qu'on irait pas chercher Maxime
on va voir où il est qu'est-ce qu'il
fait Maxime il est pas là il est pas là
il est là
allez on va le suivre
il est passé là
il est revenu là
je vois un cache-cache avec Maxime
il est pas là
il s'asseoir non mais quand même pas
on va passer derrière ah ouais belle
démarche effectivement
champion français
qui se promène
qui attend le coup il doit être comme
nous il y a pas l'air trop angoissé
et on le voit passer
on va passer là
c'est vraiment
ouais ça rigole pas
trop fière de montrer la réelle
technique et oui oui je suis je suis mvl
et oui il marche trop vite alors là on
l'a retrouvé là
il repasse
ah non
on va les revoir
il a pas bougé
12 30
12 30 à la
autant pour qu'il passe déjà une dizaine
de minutes là
sur sur son coup
c'est quand l'annonce de l'équipe de
France
pour le Championnat d'Europe
c'est pas
Maxime Lagarde rikikit dans le chat de
vous en dire plus au courant c'est pas
alors il a joué quoi
tout ça pour ça
alors
prends son temps prends ton temps 12-20
contre 19 minutes et 25 + 10 certes
il arrive il va se lever il s'assoit il
va jouer un tempo c'est tellement lui
[Musique]
c'est plus fatigué en marchant quand
réfléchissant
à la partie
c'est des bons coups c'est sûr c'est bon
quoi c'est sûr qu'il est mieux
deux pièces en moins pour Abdou ouais
bon on va pas s'enflammer non plus mais
c'est qui B3 une grosse menace
en vrai je vois pas trop comment la part
si quelqu'un a une idée je prends
je prends l'idée allez dites-moi dame B6
ouais mesdames Messi je voulais faire
quand même
et comme ça je me souviens
quand même les cases alors certes c'est
moins grave je gagne pas de pion mais
quand même
pas plaisir cette position à jouer elle
est déprimante mais bon après il joue
les ouvertures faut voir aussi les
ouvertures qui jouent hein
ça risque du métier quand on se joue
genre de truc
ça peut mal tourner parfois
ouais Abdou qui pourrait prendre 10
minutes
allez
on sait pas du tout ce qu'il va faire
c'est l'enfer c'est l'enfer cette
position avec les Noirs quel cauchemar
ouais alors c'est 4 et puis on prend des
quatre proposés mais bon film même si je
prends bêtement
roi G2 cavalier F3
et je te demande si tu sais compter
la tête la tête et un demi point
simplement devant voilà qu'est-ce qu'il
a joué
ok comme le chat comme le chat twitch de
chascom fr il joue pas mieux je joue pas
mieux
en même temps il y a pas trop d'autres
coups
si un petit coup de ma F2 pour
ce que je veux dire on crée un vis-à-vis
mais qui est B3 a l'air pas mal
aussi
bon vous savez quoi moi je pense que
Maxime il va jouer en moins d'une minute
je sais pas trop quoi
mais d'un F2 a l'air pas mal je trouve
que B3 aussi j'aime bien
il y a aussi C4 qui est quand même
toujours dans les dans l'esprit où on
affaiblit ce pioncer mais après c'est
pas sûr qu'on puisse attaquer après
qu'il y avait trois fois trois il y aura
des quatre qui va arriver donc ça
pourrait ne pas aller
Damas 5 c'était nul je crois parce que
B3 attaque la dame on perdant et joue
quand même donc ouais
ça fait un gros écart
ne pas donner de tempo gratuit
à votre adversaire
alors quel bb3 menace 3 clairement
gagnant
alors il se lève encore vas-y Maxime
reste assis reste assis
à son adversaire tu fais vraiment
n'importe quoi
je vais te raser
ah on peut faire ça peut-être
bonne chance
bonne chance peut-être ces quatre le
mieux comme le chat allez-y proposez vos
coups de toute façon il les joue donc C4
on avait dit x 3
et maintenant on fait quoi
c'est l'enfer
c'est l'enfer parce que regarder quand
on va là
peut-être gratter le pion donc faut
faire plus on prend des trous
intermédiaires dame prend
on peut faire ton fd8 ouais
effectivement keb3 t'aurais fd8 pour
avoir X3 D4 mais est-ce que ça je bouge
comme ça un petit coup de tour c'est un
ça peut être simple quand même
c'est pas drôle ton C1 et après on va
prendre et jouer Kiss 5 cauchemar
cauchemar pour
[Musique]
ignorer 5 mais c'est quoi la raison de
faire ça en fait
Maxime s'il peut encaisser le pion il va
encaisser le pion on le connaît il a
joué quoi
des 4
bon premier coup qui vient
c'est fou des deux il y a 5 peut-être
des quatre bien joué
à la première difficulté venue
peut-être comme ça
pour envoyer cavalier par là mais par là
la tour par là ou l'autre et quand même
beaucoup de faiblesse dans le noir
je vois bien faire un truc comme ça
notre ami Maxime
parce que H4 ok H4 oui oui non H4 H4 ça
se regarde aussi oui bien sûr quoique
mais il y a toujours
H4 massage 5 H6 et on va être obligé de
bouger la tour à un moment j'ai un
retour des 8
et 5
mais est-ce qu'on a vraiment accompli
beaucoup en faisant ce H4 H5 H6 je
trouve pas honnêtement je préférerais
essayer de m'organiser à l'eldame
mais bon c'est un choix de riche
c'est quand même très agréable
c'est 4 nous propose
sur
sur H4 C4 ça marche pas bien parce qu'il
y a cahier prend des quatre
il y a même pu on prend d'ailleurs
ça c'est fini
et surpuis on prend simplement
ah c'est 4 pour les blancs pardon je
comprends pas c'est l'âge non non parce
que comment on attaque ce pion après
à 5 va arriver et A4 et ça va être dur
d'attaquer ce pion ce fou va pas jouer
en fait on sait argent c'est quatre
bizarrement en s'auto enferme le fou
j'aime pas
mais après c'est vrai que oui
oui
c'est vrai que c'est du
c'est du One Way trafic comme on dit
mais il prend il prend et je vous donne
ces deux
on est bien pas de raison de pas faire
ça cette minute d'avance pour Maxime
agrafe qui joue les coups naturels je
dirais
le plan naturel
même ces deux attention ok c'est 5
grosses menaces parce qu'attends si on
vient là on vient là
ok c'est 5 c'est pas anodin comme coup
toujours ces pièces on aimerait mettre
le cavalier aussi mais je crois déjà là
c'est trop lent qui a été 8 on va faire
ça
et de me prendre des quatre donc ça ça
ne va pas
comment on fait ici
bruit de perceuse oh là là là je vais
fermer la fenêtre oh c'est BTP là qui
travaille tout le temps
c'est
en train de refaire un appartement dans
la rue
en face de chez moi alors parfois il y a
personne
désolé et oui les travaux à Paris alors
là c'est même pas dans la rue c'est dans
un appartement mais en face la fenêtre
en face
j'habite à Paris ouais pas dans le 20e
non dans le 11e
on est pas loin on est voisins
ouais du BTP la 15h ah ouais à 15h à 15h
c'est l'heure du travail
à 17h normalement
il y a encore
Maxime 8 minutes d'avance et qui a une
très très belle position sur h3g5 on va
faire je pense j'ai 5 tout simplement ça
sera l'avantage des blancs cette
ouverture de position
ados à torov dans le dur terrible
ouais c'est ça ouais
c'est un massacre cette partie manasquée
c'est 5 menace fous des deux c'est
énorme menace tours c'est énorme ce qui
fait Maxime bachelagrave main gauche
il est gaucher ça tombe bien mais il a
joué à gauche cette partie
vraiment H3 je prends F4 5 kf5 je te
fais G4 puis on prend que B3 MC2 je te
joue les cases il a pas fait un calcul
de la partie pour l'instant
c'est une boucherie
c'est aucune chance c'est 10 classes
d'écart là sur la partie
tout simplement
ouais c'est là on voit pas on voit même
pas on comprend même pas pourquoi d'où
ça te ref
est venu quoi
ton rêve D8
ok ok
il va faire tourner 5 sur fouder 2
un petit coup de fou des deux
ça marche pas de pain à mon avis
ok c'est 5 pour faire cavaler aussi
peut-être ok c'est 5 ton dessin que
j'aime pas trop donne un peu de de je
fous des deux est tellement naturel
tellement fort et il a joué quoi et il a
joué est-ce qu'il m'a fait mentir
et non il a joué fou des deux menace x 5
attention première menace
il va la voir il va faire tourner 5
ou à 5 à 5 plutôt parce que tour des 5
je fais tourcer un déjà laquelle
laquelle
la tour derrière
doubler
tripler même dame C4
pas mal ça aussi
toi
jouer très rapidement par Maxime
non pardon qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a
fait fout des deux cahier des 8 ou je
raconte n'importe quoi
pardon autant pour moi
et donc maintenant
comment on fait
comment on fait avec les Blancs ça me
semble pas si évident
c'est un bon système de défense qui est
C5
il a
bien raison
alors
c'est pas mal joué son truc bon c'est un
truc de défense évidemment mais au moins
il fait jouer son cavalier c'est vrai
que dans un
scénario miracle sont fous va revenir
comment on accentue la pression ici avec
les Blancs c'est toute la question
j'aurais envie de remettre madame par là
et de doubler ça serait mon setup idéal
mais ça perd du temps
pas mal
x 5 à 3 x 5 mauvaises nouvelles donc ça
c'est pas bon ça serait évidemment
désirable fois 5
après on peut essayer de faire DAMS
c'est ce qu'il est en train de réfléchir
à ça
mais après la route est longue hein pour
mater ce fou quand même défend bien le
roi
tout rêve de aller sur HT tendance à pas
il y a trop de faiblesses là regardez il
y a trop de faiblesses
sur ce sur cette là pour pour qu'on joue
de l'autre côté même ces quatre me
semble pas mal
j'ai même un de ces quatre
oh là là il y en a qui ont les rêves yes
Mama freestyle que vous avez c'était la
même ouverture le même type de position
pourrie pour les noirs et tout à fait
c'est vrai
je vous rappelle de ce match de
il me fait mentir il veut combiner la
taxe sur les deux ailes
OK
le Roi peut venir là tranquillement
pourquoi il fait pas à 5 c'est ça que je
pige pas
et c'est 5 peut-être
5 à 4 pour avoir un peu de jeu mais bon
c'est vrai que c'est éphémère comme
comme je
ouais
il empêche que c'est 5 parce que
maintenant il y a le pion en B2
très logique il fait jouer ses pièces à
d'où ça tombe il se défend pas mal je
trouve
ça paraît
assez
improbable vu sa position des pins
qui était quand même assez
catastrophique
donc
pour jouer tour C2 pour jouer de ton
serre je vous avais parlé de ça tourne
c'est de Tours C1 et en plus on libère
on protège le pion B2 donc on libère ce
cavalier par exemple sur A5 déjà il y a
pas 4 à 5h d'être une gaffe pourquoi
parce que c'est cloué
4 menaces voilà on a compris la menace
menace X5 attention il faut prendre des
huit et dame prend ses 6 parce que la
tour est clouée
donc première menace deuxième menace
deux fois 5
comment on l'empêche déjà c'est pas
évident comme six bof bof aussi
sur C2 dans ma 4 on remet à 5 et on se
garde peut-être pour ces quatre tour
c'est un ou tours c'est de ton C1
Adam B5 c'est tous les jours la finale
tous les jours
tous les jours on joue ouf j'aime pas ça
peut-être je fais ça
pas bon ah parce qu'il y a ça et ça et
ça
non
je suis curieux quand même peut-être ça
il y a plus rien
me semble pas même si je fais tourner
trop facile le fou joue pas c'est une
torture il a joué
il a joué aussi Abdou et Tours ces deux
jouets par le champion français pour C2
et oui simple comme bonjour j'ai pas
compris ce coup droit F2 mais bon après
tout pourquoi pas il y a tout son temps
Maxime va chez Lagrave et il le prend
il le prend son temps il a bien raison
14 minutes contre 4 minutes 10 minutes
d'avance
c'est assez impressionnant fouet fuite
pour jouer c'est 5 mais c'est d'une
passivité qu'est-ce que c'est pénible à
jouer pour les pour les noirs
faut toujours avoir un œil sur les
menaces
alors est-ce qu'on va doubler ou on va
jouer dans ma carte d'abord
et le roi aussi
mais quand même les pièces sont trop
loin maintenant
il joue il joue il joue en confiance
quand il y a pas de question
critique qui se pose je vous invite tout
simplement
il a bien raison il y a pas de souci
là-dessus dans ma 4 tours
on regardera plus tard on se concentre
sur Maxime croyez Maxime Maxime la gagne
bon bah il y a de bonne chance ça se
jouera ça sera un mano Amano avec avec
Raja BOV pour la victoire finale c'est à
peu près clair
donc c'est important de creuser aussi
les cars avec les
avec ceux qui sont derrière parce que
attention des clients comme programme et
compagnie peuvent gagner quand même
beaucoup de parties même Abdou cette
Europe
allez Maxime
la position normalement oui c'est vrai
que c'est typique
typique mvl avec cette position
technique
des petites choses à calculer
normalement ce qui fait très bien
c'est la dernière heure et Maxime ce
sera la dernière ronde peut-être pour
une victoire au bout pour un des deux
mais on en est pas là il faut déjà
attention c'est jaune joueur sont très
résilients
et il prend du temps
en train de choisir probablement les
prochains coups
on va voir
allez je parie sur
mon pari ton FC
on en pense quoi
faites des prédictions allez
ce qui trouve le bon coup ne gagne rien
bref trois stoon oui bien sûr
tout c'est
moi aussi je parie
de rikikits
ça c'est la grosse côte c'est la grosse
côte du dame français 6 on va voir
j'ai fermé la je vais ouvrir la fenêtre
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
ils font une pause là il faut une petite
pause de deux heures là le BTP
je vais aller voir moi je vais leur dire
ils ont trop travaillé aujourd'hui je
suis témoin vous êtes tous témoins
il y a tout rachat aussi peut-être c'est
pour ça
ouais à l'époque il fait trop chaud
c'est pas une vie dans ma cachez
M8 crosy je crois que tu as été le ouais
c'est un
j'étais pas loin quand même j'allais
dire à quatre ou ton FC bon c'est dans
ma 4
il y a deux autres bravo vous n'avez
rien gagné
plus de quiz plus de mug c'est la rue
ils sont collector maintenant
alors
et bien bonne chance quand même x 5
arrive
dame B5 alors la finale est trop pourrie
en plus
elle est vraiment non
cauchemar cette finale
on va faire ça ça va pas du tout il joue
c'est 5
il joue ses 5 à 12 à taureau ok ok ok
donc maintenant il a plus peur de tout
prendre X5 est plus on sait si c'est
donc il est plus en prise
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici
tu paries
ah ça y est j'ai lancé un mode de Paris
j'adore
quand est-ce que la Française des jeux
va nous laisser parier sur les échecs ça
va être beau
ok
1 x 5 quand même
bien avec KFC quand même non
ça ne gâche rien mais ça n'arrivera pas
tracez pas évident je sais pas
quand il y aura plus de nul à ranger
ouais parce que
69 excuse-moi au foot au tennis il y a
pas des
quand même
effectivement
peut-être que il faut enlever les
propositions de nulle pour faire des
périodes aux échecs parce que sinon nul
est trop probable
X5
ouais mais si même dans ma vie ne perd
pas mesdames 8 créer une menace quand
même fois 5 OK
il est dans son idée mvl
on peut parler sur un joueur là on a un
tournoi mais pas sur une partie pas en
France qui quitte c'est interdit en
France ouh là là là rikiki ce qui fait
choisi légal
qui est pour lui
en France il a pas le droit de parier
sur les échecs ouh là là là là ah mais
on pourrait ah oui d'accord ou je crois
que tu faisais un truc illégal j'ai eu
très peur
ouais on pourrait parler sur un tournoi
et pas sur une partie c'est vrai aussi
tout à fait on reprend alors tout les
corners
évidemment ou c'est une gaffe pourquoi
c'est une gaffe dame C4 jouer à tempo
c'était pas le bon coup qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait jouer ah il a joué trop vite
dame 8 oh le coup était gagnant d'un M8
attaque le pionger pourquoi c'est
gagnant parce que sur cavalier F7
la tour est plus défendue et d'un meute
3G7 seul coup et maintenant il y avait
le terrible qui est français 5 pourquoi
ça a gagné ce truc là j'en sais rien
faut penser 5 qu'est-ce qui se passe
tour H1 maths
regardez comment c'est joli K6 je vous
demande d'avoir un parce qu'elle est
vraiment joli tourrage C3 prend ouais je
suis et là bam bam
très très jolie
donc dame 8 était un avantage
complètement gagnant alors il a joué
quoi il a joué dame C4 qui est dans
l'esprit l'âme B7 vous prend pour prend
et rouage G3 il a toujours ce cavalier
et maintenant il se cavalier contre ce
fou qui était terrible il va combiner
les attaques sur les deux ailes tour à
champ tourage de va arriver
est une faiblesse mais ouais très très
jolie très jolie
après c'est sa stratégie aussi de jouer
vide de mettre la pression au temps et
de dire ok je joue pas toujours le coup
le plus précis mais en tout cas je joue
des bons coups rapidement et c'est ce
qui me permet d'avoir 9 minutes
maintenant contre 3
c'était dur c'était dur mais
effectivement
il a pas investi de temps si l'investit
du temps si on lui dit un truc à trouver
il le trouve en 10 secondes
c'est toujours pareil
alors tour de cette qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire Abdou sur une tour sur la colonage
il veut faire tout rachète ça c'est
clair
c'est tout à fait clair
et je tourage de tourrage 7 et
maintenant
et maintenant
on va changer une paire de Tours ça
c'est à peu près certain
pour FH1
ok ok ok
et quand même les blancs sont très très
bien
oh là là c'est repartir la perceuse
tu fais 200 degrés faut arrêter de
travailler
trop dur sans son travail
je vais engueuler par la fenêtre non
je vais couper quand même moi j'entends
beaucoup
trop
c'est pas possible
ah ouais c'est mieux ouais faut que
j'invite à boire un verre sur un maximum
demain
non non mais c'est pas un voisin c'est
les travaux qui sont faits en tout cas
la fenêtre ouverte et il coupe du bois
enfin où il coupe un truc je sais pas
et de refaire un appartement
alors
c'est quand même 12 minutes 2 minutes
contre neuf c'est l'heure de la vue du
dessus c'est l'heure de se mettre dans
le public et non pas avec cette caméra
c'est laquelle déjà je crois que c'est
la 5 c'est celle là on va se mettre dans
le public où est-ce qu'on se met on se
met là
on se met là on est bien là à côté du
poteau là
on va être bien voilà
un peu parce qu'on aime pas être à côté
des gens
on va se mettre là la pendule on va la
tourner
et on va la mettre là 8 minutes 35
contre
2 15 pour Abdou 7 évidemment ça craint
ça craint pour Abdou
allez place vip première rang allez hop
je me décale
[Musique]
on est pas bien là
VIP comme un Roland Garros
regarde on peut voir la pendule
alors
ton programme
et c'est pas si facile mais bon
cette 40 contre deux cases effectivement
pour nous ça torof c'est pas le moment
le plus marrant de la journée ça c'est
sûr mais ça tient alors damsir dans ma
chambre ça pourrait être des plans mais
ça qui aura fou G7 c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'il faut G7 qui défend très bien
la casach 8 et qui défend en général
très bien le roi
pour demain
alors
est-ce qu'on va pas
ramener ce qui est arrivé vers C4 ouvert
F3 le cavalier il sert plus trois
grandes choses à mon avis ici donc c'est
l'heure
c'est l'heure de c'est l'heure il a joué
cadeau Maxime Vacher la grave
et il va jouer à 7
ok est-ce qu'il voudrait pas il faut
essayer de changer les dames pour Abdou
c'est clair c'est le bon dealer
ça marche B4 pourquoi pas B4 B5
et on se crée une majorité avec les deux
pions
qui valait F3 peut-être peut-être
qu'elle va F3 intéressant bien sûr keV 3
donc même des 5 qu'est-ce qu'on ferait
c'est ça le problème changer les dames
mais bon après on peut on peut
s'infiltrer comme ça
quand même pas mal
très bien
allez il fait plaisir Maxime il fait
très plaisir
ouais cavalier F3 pour cavalier H4
certes mais je vais faire ranger 7 et
joue BK
ça fera une dame
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur un 6 il va
simplement casser le pion c'est ça
on peut pas reprendre si on prend la
dame elle pion si on prend du fou on se
fait clouer
c'est le désastre
tourbé 7 contre-attaque
mais ce qu'on peut pas prendre
est-ce qu'on peut pas prendre en C5
ce qu'on peut pas prendre en C5 puis on
prend c'est 5
c'est quoi l'idée
si on peut prendre il va prendre
ça il y a même pas de il y a même pas de
suspense
et comme ça si on fait un coup comme ça
qu'il y a du perpète dans l'air
il encaisse il en VL évidemment qu'il
encaisse
tombé de va être joué à mon avis quoi
d'autre
quoi d'autre et c'est jouer tomber de
tomber de fait peur ou pas il y a un
léger décalage
et j'ai décalage de 3-4 secondes bon ben
ils sont en Inde on est en France
problème léger vraiment
pas méchant
attention ça
je raconte des histoires ou pas
et ouais nul
c'est pas possible
Décathlon
c'est vrai j'ai pas pensé à ça
tout simplement
je trouve ça beaucoup de jeux quand même
je trouve que ça donne du jeu pour pas
grand chose alors que les il y a deux
coups les blancs les noirs avaient aucun
contre jeu
je peux faire ça certainement
ça va pas chercher loin contre je a
priori
on va voir pourquoi se dirige mvl qui a
4 minutes contre 2 attention il prend
son temps mais il prend son temps au bon
moment je trouve
belle partie
alors dame prend
ton C2 qui est 4
parce que ça sauve ce genre de truc
je crois pas
ça va être trop dur
3 jouer par Maxime
H2O à toute blind qui est proche de
c'était plus ou moins forcé ok j'avais
pas vu le
la suite après 5 pour être honnête
vous jouez attaque le pion et dame B6
c'est exactement ce que je me disais
et on essaie de
on a le bon tandem
B6 quasi obligatoire il me semble qu'il
prend des quatre grosses quand même
donc quoi d'autre honnêtement
que d'un B6 je vois pas
comment
tu fais comment pas si facile
ça y est les géométrie de Maxime là
ça c'est bien vu ça ça c'est bien vu
dans ma cadre
ouh là là là c'est pas mal ça
on fait comment maintenant
très très compliqué là
pour pour avoir complètement cuit en
fait
bien joué
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort quand il joue
comme ça franchement c'est épatant
ça ça
c'est vraiment ah oui on peut pas de
façon on peut pas quitter la protection
de ce pion ça aide
petit à petit on a même pas besoin de
laisser les échecs on va faire watch 3
d'abord et ensuite qui est ici bon c'est
complètement terminé mais je crois que
c'est complètement terminé de toute
façon dans ma cave Maxime en super
confiance 4 minutes contre 30 secondes
performance XXL dans cette partie il
aura pas lâché
pas fini mais bon on va pas de coup
on voit pas de coup là je vois pas de
coup
Dame des 8 dame C6 je crois dame D8 dame
C6 attaque ce pion attaque le fou alors
7 et il se prend d'amener 7 ah bah c'est
avant qu'on a vu
alors ça va pas du tout
Dame des 7 x 7 bien sûr qu'il va prendre
ce pion
et oui prends du cavalier évidemment
et on a trois qui est C6 ce sont ses
il va jouer quoi il peut rien faire il
doit jouer de la Macif dame B6 il jouait
à 5 d'abord ok à 5 on peut même jouer à
4 si on a envie d'être cruel de très
méchant
si on veut très méchant on joue à 4
quoi qu'il y aura dame B4 demain j'aime
bien
c'est une gaffe
à cause de ça
non comment pourquoi c'est une gaffe
3 mais je vois rien voilà non faut que
je mette mon F3 alors
A4 et K6 la même ça c'est gagnant
bien sûr
bon il prend sur échec ça peut pas être
mauvais ouais fuite attention on perds
3 oh il y a pas de perpète du tout
et sur dame prend un 4 vas-y je tiens
et il encaissé ici il me l'associe sa
tension attention
va-t-il le jouer oh là là le public est
en la foule est en délire là la foule se
lève
quasiment
mais c'est cavalier H4 est encore
peut-être encore plus rapide c'est un
artiste mvl
on le sait que c'est un artiste
magnifique
[Musique]
et je vous donne un projet 6 ok ok
c'est fini
c'est pas le Move
applaudit on applaudit dans le public
applaudir incroyable
incroyable c'est la foulard délire en
Chine
il a joué quoi dame 8 et non je joue pas
la finale attention
le pion fonce
il va jouer shake évidemment
il va jouer chez
ou on le connaît ou qu'on le connaît
ou regardez moi ça
abandon abandon roi G8 il y avait G6
tout simplement la marche 7 et j'ai
cette terminado victoire impériale de
Maxime vas chier La Grave et si on
allait voir Raja bof tiens pour lui
porter l'oeil un peu
alors allez
on est comme ça nous
et il a quatre et demi sur 6 comme ça me
demande pas lu plus combien il a quatre
et demi sur 6 il fait une journée
incroyable à deux demi sur trois il a
été il a été très très bon on va aller
voir s'il reste des parties ou pas
peut-être la cam 1 c'est à Christina
gamer
il reste
gooche il reste script show contre
Prague
et
ce qui nous reste une partie
intéressante avec
on va aller voir très très bonne
nouvelle avec
[Musique]
mvl qui se retrouve en tête
que ça donne ça donne une poubelle pour
gamer
on va se reposer en de la salle
et demain pour ceux qui partent 11h30
11h30 demain on va on va suivre
évidemment la fin de la partie est-ce
que c'est une forteresse ou pas ça pas
l'air entre arrêt et Christina et gamer
mais en tout cas
ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut regarder
c'est ça c'est le résultat on voit deux
parties qui sont encore en cours mais
victoire de Maxime vacherin grâce à ça
devant adjabof à 4 sur 6 qui vient de
prendre une bulle et gokuche ouais il
pourrait revenir un point les autres
mais même pas même pas sûr donc là il
est très très bien parti il est en tête
Maxime Acher La Grave ouais ouais non il
fait un gros tournoi là trois victoires
3 nuls évidemment c'est impressionnant
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il a gagné à
Krishna contre Vincent gamer est-ce
qu'il nous reste une dernière partie à
regarder
ou pas on va regarder on va regarder on
va regarder tout de suite
ah mais non moi j'ai fait n'importe quoi
moi c'est la partie de la Krishna
pardon pardon pardon on va voir ouais
la partie de la qui devrait remporter
cette partie
mais effectivement
mais clairement de gagner le temps
rapide être pas pour le tournoi de Blitz
à part pour la confiance mais au niveau
du point on repart à zéro
et on part pour différentes de Blitz
et est-ce que ça gagne ça ou pas gamer
en difficulté
qui meurt en grosse difficulté dans ce
tournoi
il se défend
et oui c'est pas le champion de partir
rapide à chaque fois
ah il a pas gagné le tournoi il restera
attention
alors quatre émissions
[Musique]
parce que c'est vraiment gagnant pour un
cristal cette finale je sais pas mais
plutôt
j'irai plutôt oui mais je suis pas sûr
rien n'est sûr dans ce monde
ce qu'on va là
j'en sais rien
ouais si c'est une forteresse oui c'est
ça ouais mais bon après non en fait
c'est démontré un plan parce
qu'effectivement ça va pas il va faire
tourner 6
il va attendre pour l'instant il voit
pas de plan clairement
du point de vue de son attitude générale
il voit pas de plan
voilà
ok c'est pour dire à gamer tu joues ce
que tu veux
oui c'est ça
si elle est bleu qui nous dit rien n'est
sûr sauf la mort et la peau comme disent
les Anglais ouais
tout à fait
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va il
va faire un coup il fait ouais ok
je vois pas comment on perce honnêtement
mais au feeling ça a l'air de
ça a l'air de percer tout ça
alors madame des 7 il tourne un peu il a
bien raison dans la Krishna
et ok Dame des 8 maintenant il y a plus
droit F6 parce qu'on ferait d'un fuite
quoi que c'est pas 100% sûr mais c'est
probable
et comment on fait ici
tout aussi OK
moi j'ai 5 pour faire F5 ou pas il
tourne en rond il arrive pas hein
il n'y arrive pas à Krishna
il est en galère
et franchement je vois pas de plangas il
faut faire F5 certainement un moment ou
un autre ça passera pas F5 qu'est-ce
qu'il faut d'abord mettre la dame par là
peut-être
non il fait Dame des quatre ok je sais
pas quelle idée échec ok il revient
il va faire il va revenir aussi
peut-être ça dans la suite
et ranger 3
ok où vas-tu
où vas-tu
le sais-tu
je crois qu'il en sait rien il tourne
c'est laborieux mais laborieuse c'est
peut-être mieux en fait tout simplement
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans l'autre
partie
on va voir les résultats rapidement et
dans l'autre partie il y a eu nul on se
joue encore entre
quelque chose peut revenir un peu ouais
si il faut qu'il fasse nul comme ça
Maxime à un point et demi d'avance sur
les autres joueurs autre que Raja bof
mais on va voir qui essaye de gagner
leur vie propose qu'elle le plan je sais
pas
à mon avis c'est typiquement le genre de
position on leur dit propose pas trop de
plans
je crois qu'il y a pas de gains en fait
je crois que c'est
plus je regarde plus je me dis que c'est
nul
de base qu'il favorit du tournoi c'est
ce que j'ai dit en début c'est très
ouvert comme tournoi très homogène il y
a pas de monstres de monstres des
rapides à part peut-être un VL
d'ailleurs
mais en tout cas en blitz
un peu moins rapide mais voilà il y a
pas de Magnus ou Nakamura qui sont
à chaque fois qu'ils s'inscrit dans un
toit de rapido de Blitz ils sont
automatiquement favoris
mais voilà ça restait très ouvert entre
gamer abdosa torov Google
fait une superbe coupe du monde bon
voilà il y avait cinq six joueurs c'est
crédible qui gagne de tondre
clairement
sont quand même assez monstrueux en aux
échecs en général et en rapides aussi
ils sont bons à tous les formats
alors comment on fait on ne sait pas
c'est la galère
alors moi j'ai ces trois G5
et tourner 6 menace échecs c'est une
gaffe ça
et pourquoi on peut pas faire F5 là
pourquoi il a pas fait chèque ah il
avait peur que le
F5 non
c'est une chanson en or
OK
il a réussi à les organiser là j'ai
l'impression
toi aussi c'est F5 il a eu
à l'usure
ouais mais ça ça va pas
ça ça ne va pas du tout ça c'est sûr que
ça va pas c'est sûr que c'est foutu
je vois pas en quel monde c'est une
forteresse ce truc
et il n'y a pas pris d'accord donc échec
il vient en G2
ouais je dis ok mais il y a plein de
pions c'est ça le problème c'est qu'il a
le cavalier
et le pion attaqué
le pion tout simplement
F5 et aussi tu entends
pour ça qu'il réfléchit à riz
c'est plus logique de prendre le pion je
trouve
non
c'est pas mal hein
ouais ça va être ça va être chaud il
rejoue plus Maxime et on joue demain
11h30 je prends l'antenne 10 minutes
avant 10 15 minutes avant venez nombreux
on va peut-être assister à une victoire
de ton one Maxime et franchement c'est
pas tous les jours donc faut en profiter
faut pas bouder notre plaisir
qui est rangé quatre ok
ça a l'air il y a trop de pions passer
là pour un seul homme
qu'est-ce qui va jouer
alors cavalier 3 peut-être
que trois jouets
en F2
et maintenant
on a tout misé sur spion donc faut le
pousser
d'abord il va faire quelques échecs
parce qu'il a peur du contre jeu comme
ça donc
j'aime pas tout F3 échec ou le coup de
massue n'a pas vu sur WordPress
évidemment il gagne du temps maintenant
il va pouvoir pousser attention
et apparemment j'ai quatre mélancés il
pousse j'ai gagné du temps à 4 il était
pas content
attention
il y a plus de fourchette maintenant
c'est prestigieux qui a
comme ça c'est toujours prestigieux
et il avance le roi c'est apparemment
une faute à cinq croisés 5 mais là
qu'est-ce qu'il a calculé là il est
assis là qu'est-ce qui nous fait
de faire ça
oui c'est ça
apparemment pas le plus précis mais
clairement pour empêcher G3 ok ça a
beaucoup de sens
et donc sur Wave 4 il va 6 j'ai 3 à 7 g
de la il y a une très mauvaise nouvelle
c'est un problème
donc il fait
un C6 fait tour 3 d'accord ça c'est
logique
il va venir a priori avec le roi vers le
pion
ouais
et revient ok gamer il est d'accord avec
lui évidemment va changer c'est quasi
certain
roi des deux sûrement
roi des 1
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
pas évident pour incruster
il faut qu'il fasse attention quand même
à sa pendule
et maintenant
et maintenant comment on fait j'ai trois
y a 6
apparemment il y a une c'est quoi la nul
on est tous des trois rois
est-ce que c'est la troisième fois ou
pas
non oui
et il dit exactement comment il faut
faire dans vos parties n'oubliez pas
vous arrêter la pendule vous dites
normalement il faut noter le coup
mais là il a arrêté la pendule il a dit
c'est trois fois la même position et il
a raison quand je veux jouer tout au 3
ça sera trois fois la même position et
il a complètement raison selon moi ouais
et 3 fois même position ça va être
accordé regardez les rois
et nul ouais l'ordinateur dit oui
l'ordinateur dit oui en tout cas
moi aussi
ouais
il était gagnant mais bon c'était pas
facile avec peu de temps comme ça
il avait trouvé le chemin
ouais dommage on va voir la fin il est
pas bien là
content quand même de pas se prendre
trois buts aujourd'hui
et voilà nul accordé nul entre les deux
joueurs et on va faire un petit retour
sur le résultat et donc il y a une entre
quelque chose qui est Prague victoire
est un sens de Maxime agrave ça
bref on n'aurait pas pu choisir mieux
comme résultat c'était nous qui avions
choisi résultat pour cette ronde on
aurait choisi ça et on a le classement
avec Maxime va chez Lagrave en tête 4,5
[Musique]
et à Krishna 2 et donc demain on aura
peut-être une dernière on aura déjà bof
mvl où ça jouera le gain du temps à très
probablement ou peut-être certainement
Raja BOV sera obligé de gagner ça va
nous faire ça nous fait une belle fin de
tournoi et cette fin de tournoi
elle se déroule demain à partir de 11h30
mais je prends l'antenne d'ici vers
11h20 quelque chose comme ça
et je vous attends
encore plus nombreux je l'espère
poursuivre la victoire peut-être dans le
tournoi de partir rapide du tata style
chess India de évidemment Maxime va chez
Lagrave si je joue comme aujourd'hui
on est bien si joue comme aujourd'hui on
est favoris ça c'est sûr
ravi d'avoir commenté ces parties et je
vous dis à demain merci infiniment de
m'avoir suivi ciao ciao
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement et saviez-vous
que vous pouvez pimenter vos parties en
ligne et vous analyses avec des emojis
il vous suffit de cliquer sur l'icône